hey there i'm mark traeger and i sit
down with evan carmichael in a ten part
series because i was able to build uh an
over million dollar a year business ten
years ago now i was at in the recession
i was at the point of my life where i
had no revenue i had no employees i had
no clients and i thought i was going to
shut down my business i was able to go
from zero to a million dollars plus by
following some simple steps
in this 10 part series evan and i sit
down and we break through everything we
look at operations we look at how to
build your portfolio we look at where to
get your customers from the first video
starts right now it's going to help you
take your business to the next level
what's up believe nation i am testing a
new series on how to build a million
dollar company and i thought i'd start
with a friend of mine mark draper draper
that's awesome let's keep that in mark
drager
i've only known you for 12 years i can't
even say my name i'm the best i'm so
happy i fled the intro we got to keep
all this in uh mark has built an awesome
million dollar plus business
in the
what are you doing
this is dog just randomly showing up of
course this is fun
uh what do we teach people do we teach
you how to build an agency marketing
agency if you want to build a million
dollar plus marketing agency that is
what this series 10 part series is all
about and so do you have a quick like
something quick you want to intro say
about yourself what you do sure yeah so
i started fanta 12 years ago we started
really heavily focused on video but you
know as marketing has changed as
advertising has changed we've been able
to expand
into all assets or facets of digital
marketing and analytics because really
you wanted me to start with one piece of
value so we might as well start right
away yeah yeah yeah the okay okay yeah
yeah you go okay the only thing that
matters yeah
is the value you drive to a client it
seems basic but that's that's the only
thing that matters okay so point number
one
this video you have to drive value to
your client how do you do it
so it starts uh
with trying to figure out what your
skill sets are so what are you good at
you know if you're really great at
design and you like marketing then it
makes more sense to start a creative
type of agency if you're really great at
websites and building websites and it
makes more sense to start a digital type
of agency
whatever your passion is and whatever
you focus on is where your business will
go anyway so the first place to start is
figuring out what are you really good at
and you don't have to be the best at it
but when you're starting you know you
want a few people to be able to say like
oh you got a gift here you're talented
or that's really good or we really like
it and it seems super super basic but
but that that positive reinforcement is
going to help you build confidence and
get you through things and that's where
you start so for us we started with
video yeah and i went to film school
uh i i went and worked in corporate
video if you go back and look at our
stuff from 12 years ago it's not good
it's it's really really bad work and
but i started with video because that's
that's what i knew and then the video
mark became video marketing and then
video marketing became oh we need to put
this on a landing page and then the
landing page became oh can you do the
microsite and for years we had clients
asking us they said oh we love how you
do videos so much can you please do this
other stuff for us and we said no we're
just we're video agency only so so sorry
you have to go find someone else
and we would hear all these bad things
about bad experiences and finally we
said why are we why are we turning
clients away when they like us when they
like what we do why don't we apply what
we're doing to all of these other
styles of work and so that's how our
company turned into you know a
full-service digital agency or full
service marketing agency because the
clients were coming to us and saying
saying please help us with these other
things right and so it's okay to start
with just focusing on logo design or
it's okay to start with uh trying to be
the best at creating a landing page and
driving traffic to that landing page
yeah it's all about what you're good at
and then marrying up that with value
right we can't lose sight of the fact
that
like i say this to my team
it matters more what clients think about
your work
and the quality of the work okay that
bothers me because i'm uh yeah because
i'm a perfectionist right like i have
high standards so i go oh you know it
should all be about how good the work is
but it's not right it's how people feel
about the work right right so if you're
working with people and you're starting
out and you go oh i don't have a
portfolio
you have one or two people who like you
right that's that's great right like
start right right people like that i
called you draper instead of jaeger no
one likes that
no if you guys like that put in the
comments just to i'm gonna screenshot
and show mark how much you love that we
call them draver um well so the point of
this series is to get to get specific
right it's like somebody wants to build
a million dollar plus marketing agency
so tip number one is you have to know
yourself what you love doing where you
can bring the most value so i'm thinking
okay i love that i agree
now how do i what's my next step if i'm
just starting how do i figure out
maybe not even what i'm good at yet
because you may not be good at the start
but you have a passion for the thing to
get better at how do i how do i make
that decision to know yes this is the
right path
so
you can do as much planning as you want
you can do as much thinking as you want
i you know i started my company i was
really young i was 24. yeah but i
actually had written a business plan no
that sounds really fancy i had actually
printed off a bunch of other people's
websites and kind of came up with the
idea for what i wanted to start
three years earlier and and i only
remembered that like much later i found
all these notes and i was like where are
all these websites and i was like oh
yeah when i was like 19 or 20 i had this
vision of starting something yeah so
do you want to start something like ask
yourself if you want to start something
and you're really good at it then
like
it's not complicated like you just have
to start you just have to start because
it's gonna take you time to get better
and that's okay it's gonna take you time
to listen to the clients who you're
working with and and fix your operations
and all the other topics that we're to
kind of get into in other videos yeah
but there's there's not really
much magic to it other than the courage
to just say this is something i'm doing
and being okay with with uh getting
better and being okay with figuring it
out later you know when we switched
maybe three and a half four years ago
from being only video right and and the
previous video we did was how to build a
multi you know multi-million dollar or
whatever video company and now we're
talking about marketing yeah uh we just
switched yeah right i was like this is
who we are now and this is what we do
and i started talking to people i took
them up for lunch
and i said this is what we want to do
this is how we want to help and people
like that so if you want to start a
website company yeah decide okay i want
to start a website company
start talking to people about the fact
that you are now a website company yeah
and how you want to help them i get it i
mean and that's the point of this series
because it
people will overthink those things yeah
yeah yeah like like when i started we
didn't have a website for the first two
months yeah now this is in 2006 but yeah
i mean in 2006 we started the company we
started the company with no website for
for two months right uh even if you go
through um if anyone goes through the
wayback machine it's like it's it took
us four years to actually create
something that wasn't embarrassing back
machine i think they stopped you in
track no they're still keeping track
yeah if you want to go if you want to go
way back phantommedia.com like like it's
embarrassing it's embarrassing
yeah
do you not jinx me or not
uh we i was saying to someone the other
day i'm like i think we're on our fourth
logo we've only we've been around 12
years we're on our fourth logo yeah and
that's because our first bunch of logos
were really bad okay all right they just
they just weren't good
um you know we incorporated the company
because we thought like oh if we have
you know the word incorporated or
limited or company or seem big like we
just made lots of mistakes so just just
don't worry about that get started right
get started with one client that turns
into three yeah that turns into six that
turns into you know do try to do good
work try to listen so but but really the
core for kind of
the first part of it is thinking about
the type of company you want to build do
you want to be a great freelancer okay
that's running a company yeah right do
you want to be a freelancer has two or
three people working for you do you want
to have a team of 30 or 40 people that's
that's like a totally different type of
company and you're not going to be there
from day one but but you know understand
what do you need to be at to get them to
hit a million in revenue
what size can you can't do as a
freelancer can you do as a freelancer no
right so like what what size team do you
need to be at to hit a million
so a range uh
yeah i mean you're gonna be anywhere
between oh gosh maybe if you're killing
yourselves four or five people yeah up
to uh i mean up to anything i guess but
if you're yeah a thousand people you
make a million bucks you're not in
business no i mean if you're if you're
so so i'm talking about like full-time
staff yeah if you're outsourcing because
you can build a great outsource model
too we're outsourcing tons and tons of
stuff yeah i mean if you're doing a
million dollars and you only have 20
margins then you're only earning 200 000
in-house yeah so so you're only going to
have
uh
two three people on salary yeah but if
you do everything in-house and you're
doing a million dollars you might have
eight nine ten twelve it depends on your
cost of living it depends the area
you're working in yeah right so
somebody's just getting started
or they've started their agency they and
they like man i wanna be like mark in a
couple years the the biggest thing i
hear sorry after the biggest thing i
hear from people because
i have conversations once or twice a
month with other people trying to do it
yeah most people aren't starting out
okay right yeah if you're starting out
think think ahead okay most people are
doing this for a year or two okay and
they're not getting any traction okay
right are we gonna cover that in future
videos or that this is let's add it okay
it wasn't a talk okay here we go
bringing it how to gain traction but i
was gonna say yeah uh these things take
time yeah
and
there are these tipping points right you
always talk about focus on momentum yeah
right focus on momentum things things
start to pick up yeah i never i never
knew that year four would be easier than
year three right or that your three
would be slightly easier than year two
right like the longer you're doing it
the more that you're doing
uh it's not that things get easier but
you're just
more well-known you know more people
you've had more opportunities you've
done more work you're you're in the game
for longer and so focus on some momentum
but most people who feel like they're
not getting traction yeah it's because
they're only two or three years into it
or or they're four or five and then
they're not making big changes
and so
you have to be willing to make those
changes you have to give it some time so
so
going all the way back start like like
like start the clock now
start the clock tomorrow yeah so that
way you're like this is what we're doing
and don't worry about the business card
don't worry about the website start
telling people this is what you're doing
start doing free work okay start honing
your skills start talking to lots of
people right decide the type of company
you want to be think about your skill
sets and just start okay so so if
somebody's trying to go from
deciding like the point of this video is
decide what you want to
tell your company you want to be and how
you can bring value to your clients yeah
right
what are three questions that i need to
be asking myself to figure out that
problem oh very good so everybody
watching ask yourself these three
questions yeah
so i would say
what is something that you feel is easy
but you're surprised that isn't easy for
other people okay good that was that was
mind-blowing for me when i started and i
was a few years in and i started hiring
people and i got frustrated i was like i
was like this is really simple stuff
right and then i learned i was like oh
i'm just actually really good at this
right okay that's a good one but it
seems so easy to me like like i felt bad
charging people money for it right it
was so easy right but
so so that's the first question what's
something that seems really easy to you
but others are like they can't do or
they struggle with there's just value
there yeah
uh the second question
always ask yourself if you're good
enough okay right now this can be really
depressing right i ask myself i'm good
enough and i just end up with like no
i'm not okay
right so the other side of that is to
pull yourself out of that hole by
figuring out what are the few things you
can do to get better
right like i look at competition
and and i go gosh they're so good
are we even doing anything good right
and we've i've been doing this for 12
years like people look at me like i
actually had a conversation with someone
who's my competition right and he's
looking at me and he's these guys are so
good i'm looking at him going these guys
are so good and meanwhile we're like we
could be best friends because because
we're in the same place and doing the
same thing
but there's like some kind of healthy
competition there yeah so when you're
starting out look at a few people that
you think uh are achievable ask yourself
if you're good enough and then and then
like really use that not to get yourself
depressed but to close that gap right
because everybody starts somewhere right
and so if you're able to it's a kick
forward not down yeah but you're still
getting the kick yeah that would be the
second thing yeah i like it and then the
third thing i would say is
you can't be everything to everybody
okay and i still i still struggle with
this too so what's the question with
that the question would be what are
those core elements that i really should
be focusing on and doing
and what are the things that i shouldn't
be wasting my time on and saying no to
and i fall in this all the time
you know i have friends ask me to help
them with their website when i have no
time right
you gotta dump those friends do i
mr carmichael
right friends don't serve you man yeah
so so you can't be everything to
everybody yeah
when you're starting the more niche you
are yeah the like the harder and yet
easier it is so pick it so like what
would be a will be niche example
something oh if you're like i'm only
going to ever focus on logo design
right for
like
for athletes or for sports oh that's
like that's even better like like it
depends on again the type of company you
want to build right if you want to be a
starting point
like i'm going to develop websites for
the yoga industry and be the best yoga
website person and then expand from
there that's a great way to look at it
okay it's hard
but it's a fast way to grow okay all
right so when i started the company we
were doing
it's hard because when there's no one
talking to you there's no one talking to
you there's zero revenue there's nothing
happening
but how does the yoga thing make it
worse
so when i when i started we were we were
doing lots of things for lots of people
again i was like oh a little money here
and a little money here and a little
money here you know i need eight hundred
dollars and a thousand dollars is that
good uh i mean it helped it helped me
generate a hundred thousand dollars of
revenue my first year that's a lot more
than
everybody right now that was great but i
recommend when i do it again
is that the path like people are
watching like 100k like they would love
to have 100k i know but here's but
here's the problem yeah here's the
problem i had 100 creative revenue but
only only like 18 of it was doing the
stuff i wanted to do
so do you recommend that or no
if you put your foot down say this is
what i do i wouldn't do it again that
way how would you do it if you're
starting over
if
if if you're if you're like drinker
again yeah i mean i said it right this
time 24 year old gregor so
this is this is the struggle right like
like when i started my company my wife
had no income because she was just
graduating college my first daughter was
three months old and i quit my job i
quit my 40 000 year job
and i was like i'm out of here i'm going
to start my company and 100 000 revenue
yeah and that year we took home 17 000
pay right so we were living below the
poverty line for the first year so
i mean i had to hustle i had to i had to
not go bankrupt i had to make it happen
so but if i could have yeah if i could
do it again
i would say
you know what
um
we did all of that work
on all of those different things and i
still only made 17 grand
so
it was it was about having the courage
to say we'll get through that first year
things will get better and if i had
focused all my efforts only on that one
thing that we were good at maybe i still
would have made 17 or 18 grand right and
maybe i would have actually been less
busy right right it's uncomfortable not
to be busy so if you want to do the if
you want to be the yoga website person
if you want to be the web but you're two
it's better by year three it's even
better but say no to the guy who wants
you to make a car dealership website of
course or say no to the person
you say no to the person who's like oh
you seem to be pretty good design can
you do my business cards right right and
say no if you want to be a design
company be a design company if you want
to be
uh if you want to be a website company
be a website company if you want to be a
photography company do that what are you
doing more than 17k
do you love it no is it your skill set
yes
but you don't like it nope so what's
your passion
i want to be the yoga guy i don't want
to design your business card somebody
don't say no don't fall into the
temptation of just making the money and
losing a few years because that's what
people do you're going to lose a few
years is it worth costing you a few
years
right it will it will slow you down so
draeger like go back to 24 year old
drager uh
mark can you help me with my business
cards i'm going to i'm not going to
people i would have totally done it
but i shouldn't i shouldn't have i'll
pay you i'll pay you 17k just my
business cards
but that's a bottle right yeah listen it
was there was a thing there was there
was a time to get through the first year
where where this company hired us to do
landing pages right right we were
starting a video agency right but we're
doing landing pages and i i'm
outsourcing it to my wife and i'm saying
like hey copy and paste this stuff
because we needed the eleven thousand
dollars you know to come in and pay the
bills but when it is high paying and you
have bills to pay but you don't love it
do you still do it
like is that is that the life could it
save your business
or if you say like if it's gonna if
you're gonna lose your apartment yeah if
you're gonna if you're gonna not make
rent if you're not gonna make payroll
yeah if you have a gap then take it yeah
right like listen like you you gotta if
those are the case yeah if you if if it
if if you are taking that 17 grand yeah
and you are losing three months of your
time yeah to make payroll when you and
there are other things that are lower
margins waiting for you in the wings
then that's going to hold you back right
if you have nothing to do right
how many business how many businesses
you know that are starting up that have
nothing to do you're focusing on the
wrong stuff sure right but so it's it's
paying opportunities versus
non-paying options like biz dev right
getting out of talking people uh the num
the number one thing that i see holding
business owners back is they're too
selfish when they start
meaning
they they imagine that that they should
be paid first you shouldn't be paid
first right they imagine that they
should earn some kind of income like oh
if i was working for someone else i
should start some kind of income and
they rob all the operating capital out
of the company yeah right if if you
really like the the ones who take off
are the people who don't pay themselves
for two or three years yeah who uh
work um who live in the office that they
work in because they can only afford a
single rent and they don't have two
rents yeah uh when i was really trying
to kickstart three years in my business
i took out a loan
i used that loan to hire someone right
and i stopped paying myself for six
months right i remember that and my wife
was like uh hey
right i think i was like hey hey why are
you borrowing money to pay someone else
and you're not paying yourself yeah
right like like i've seen it i've seen
it with friends who go like oh we have
three partners in the business and all
partners need to earn this to live it's
right you have too many partners yeah
right you're gonna you're gonna the
company needs revenue to do what the
work it needs to do so that way later
you can be like look at how great this
company is yeah right so i i didn't know
that starting i just i was nervous to to
use any cash but even now like
like
i i feel like i should earn like double
or triple what i pay myself because i'm
worth that right um but
i'm trying to do something great here
and that takes resources yeah so
don't rob the company of that money
because because you feel like i've
worked really hard i'm entitled to this
or that right right put that off for 12
months 18 months and give yourself
little treats if you need it but like
the little treat should be like your
favorite little treat
uh early on i
gave my wife five hundred dollars to buy
new clothes
my treat was going to mcdonald's and
getting a large french fries right
sharing it with three people right like
i get it right anything this is this is
two to two and a half years in yeah yeah
right we're earning like we're like
i think i was you know seventeen i think
i went to 32 grand the next year doesn't
have to cost a lot it's a celebration
it's like hey no it was more it was more
like a surprise like like it's been two
years since we bought clothing yeah you
know like yeah
like here you go yeah have an afternoon
like you can spend a lot of you like it
feels like a lot of money we got no
money 500 bucks oh man all right right
two years she she earned that
300 bucks a month dude
you mark
what's the most important thing that you
want to talk about on on charging and
money
so
i i think for a lot of people who are
starting out especially if you're
creative yeah if you're an agency you're
going to be pretty creative person yeah
is the feeling like uh i don't want to
look at it i don't want to know like you
know i'm gonna i'm gonna ostrich it i'm
gonna put my head in the sand yeah i'm
not gonna worry about it and truthfully
it's something you have to be aware of
okay but if you do worry about it you
i'm gonna be both sides here you don't
have to worry about it that much okay
right so we're 12 years in yeah we still
price things like in this really open
safe way okay right
we just assume how much something will
cost and how much someone will pay us
and we just figure out that it's going
to work out in the end
like like it sounds it sounds crazy okay
but i am not good with numbers okay and
so the thought of of all of my
financials and all of my things the
thought of going like this is a big
project and how many hours and how much
does it cost and all of these things i'd
rather go like uh that's 80 grand
and then hope that it costs less than 80
grand to deliver
and
it sounds crazy yeah right and i've been
doing this long enough that i kind of
know what you're going to get i feel for
it but if i have to wait two weeks to
deliver a quote because i'm busy or a
week or something figuring something out
why does it take that long for most
people well some projects are really
complicated okay right and if you're
outsourcing stuff you don't know the
price until you get into it right you
don't know what you don't quite know
what's happening until you get into it
but they won't get into it until they
let them know what the price is okay and
then if you're relying on vendors you
have to go out to them and then they say
well what's the scope okay and then you
got to give them the scope and like it
could take it could take months okay so
truthfully if you're like
i think this is 12 grand okay and it's
13.
well yeah i mean you've lost a thousand
dollars for a really great opportunity
to build your portfolio
or hopefully it's
10 and you get to keep two of it or
maybe it's six and you get to keep six
of it right like like when you're
starting if you are really getting
stressed out with how to charge for
things yeah and i mean this can be a big
risk if you're going if suddenly you
landed some kind of big bank yeah and
they're like hey we want all of this
stuff
uh
you know chances are you
you're going to be too overwhelmed to
take that you're going to be too scared
to take it or they're just not going to
give it to you because you can't pass
due diligence but if something if
something big is happening it's like oh
we want this million dollar project and
you're like oh gosh i don't know if it's
going to cost me 2 million you're losing
a million dollars yeah i'm not talking
those numbers okay i'm talking when when
when you're doing an 800 project okay or
five thousand dollar project and that's
what your cost cost you five thousand
dollars to do uh what you think it's
worth okay so there's two ways to price
a business yep right whenever you're
dealing with this it's it's either going
to be based off of
your your cost to deliver with markup
so it cost me eight thousand dollars to
deliver this project i think i should
earn forty percent margin so i take
eight thousand dollars and i mark it up
okay or it's going to be based on your
hours
right but you don't do any of this stuff
later we reverse engineer it okay but
see what sense i'm saying there's
there's ways you have to price the
business either there's going to be a
hard cost plus markup yeah it's going to
be your hours i think it's going to take
140 hours to do this my hourly rate is
60 or 80 or 100 or 200 or 300 whatever
it is your hourly rate and that's your
answer
uh
or you uh you just make a number up
based on what you think it's worth right
i know it's only gonna it's only take 12
hours to do this project but
i'm experienced i'm a genius i know it
takes me 12 hours but it's worth
10 000
and then there's that's another way to
price your business right and
really you shouldn't stick to any one of
these you should be open to all of them
because it depends on the client
if if you're working with someone
who is coming to you because you're
really good at your job and they don't
have a lot of money and you like them
you're probably going to price it less
right right if you're working with
somebody who um
where it's a lot of outsourced elements
right you're like you're spending a lot
of money you probably want to protect
yourself by marking it up but the reason
why i said we reverse engineer this
later is let's say you come to us and we
go
we do this on on
most projects we'll start talking to you
and we'll say well how much budget do
you have and that's the other thing is
we ask clients like how much budget you
have to work with there's nothing wrong
with that they say i'm not quite sure
how much will it cost
it can cost anything
all right so realistically are you gonna
spend
ten thousand dollars on this you're
gonna spend two thousand dollars on this
you're gonna spend a hundred thousand
dollars on it
right like you may say you don't have a
budget but everybody knows what they
feel is reasonable and that's the
ballpark that's important to know at
least the ballpark a ballpark right and
so if someone says well
we can't see going over ten thousand
dollars okay now you have a place to
start yeah
and then you have to ask yourself can i
deliver anything for ten thousand
dollars
i think it's one of the hardest things
for people just getting started what
what do i charge for my thing
i'm gonna help you shoot this video i'm
gonna help make a website what does a
website cost well if you're if you're if
your cousin does it it's free and if you
hire somebody agency it's going to cost
you
fifty thousand dollars but but it's not
about what when you're starting it's not
about what other people charge
right it's about
so how do i figure out what i should
charge for that website or for that
video or for that instagram campaign
i i don't over complicate it like that i
say
what is the client asking for yeah
do i think i can do it yeah and if i
can't what do i need to do to be able to
do it right like maybe i can't do it but
maybe i can hire my cousin or maybe i
can hire my friend i can do this stuff
what will that cost me
and can i deliver this within their
budget because you're starting right and
when you're starting clients okay but
first you're asking for their budget
yeah so when they say mark how much is
it going to cost you to design this
website or do this landing page or make
this business card i say first question
do we have to work with
right because truthfully and it might
seem crazy because they'll say like well
like i i told you i want a website right
but it's like saying like i want to buy
a car yeah what kind of car do you want
right right you want to take a trip yep
hotel you're at flights like where are
you going what are you doing yeah right
like like these are these are very sim
most people understand this right when
they come back and think about it they
go okay i guess that makes sense because
do you want a four thousand dollar
website or a forty thousand dollar
website right they might say well of
course i want a four thousand one that's
so much cheaper i don't wanna pay more
than i have to
but it's not about that it's about it's
about what do we forget to work with
yeah from a budget point of view so the
first question back is what's your
budget
then they say i don't know mark uh you
know you're the expert on this i'm just
trying to figure it out i just want a
website perfect some people spend 10 to
20 000 on a website some people spend
fifty thousand plus some people wanna
expect a website to be like four or five
grand where are you in that right right
and they still say i don't know it's
like are you serious like
you
you must know if you're comfortable
spending eighty thousand dollars on a
website
right or if if you're like well i expect
a website to cost eight thousand now
then you can again this is when you're
starting right when you're starting you
need experience you need clients you
need people to like you you need
opportunities you need all of these
things so i don't look at it in terms of
like
every lead that comes through is a
chance for me to make money yeah every
lead that comes through is an
opportunity for me to prove myself right
and my goal is not to lose money in this
regard right right
so we talked in the previous video about
not being selfish and trying to draw out
all this money if you need this money to
live it's going to skew your motivations
it's going to make you say like i need
to take this project i need five grand
on it
i don't look at it that way i get to
take this project and i have an
opportunity to prove myself learn a
bunch of things make a bunch of
connections and hopefully i don't lose
money on it
what i also love and what you're saying
is you're you're pushing it back on the
client
and i think a lot of people will have
insecurities around that especially the
beginning so when they say
even just the question how much does it
cost already insecurities like well i
should know how much it cost and then
when you say what's your budget they say
well i don't know you're the expert then
more insecurities like i'm supposed to
be the expert i'm supposed to know i
literally go medium low high and i did
that twice with you yeah i went is it 12
grand is it 4 grand is 100 grand yeah is
it 15 grand is it 10 grand is it 50
grand yeah right like and and i and i do
that now i know there's certain things i
can't do right i've been doing this long
enough if someone wants something and
they don't have the budget yeah i know
now right uh i'm also at the point in my
business where we're telling people what
they should spend on stuff right oh well
i think you should spend this on it
but but for our first
seven or eight years we didn't price
anything that way right right and does
it it does lead to some trouble
sometimes right sometimes you get a
project where you look back on it and
you go like wow we did all of that work
and uh we didn't earn very much money
but then that's the next part of it is
is when you're in a creative field
you want every project to be the best it
can so it can be an expression of what
you're capable of what you can do and
all those things so the worst case
scenario is you do a project with a
client you don't like or they just don't
like you by the end of it
you don't do good work and you or you
can't show it and you don't earn any
money yeah right that's that to me
that's that's losing yeah if you can
either
not make money like you know i'm not
making money i'm not really doing great
work but the client loves me that's
still a win right because then you have
another opportunity to actually move up
the budgets to do the next thing to
change the things if the client's not
really that happy with you but you did
great work yep now you have a portfolio
piece yep the client's not happy with
you you didn't do great work but you had
great margins yeah well now you have
money to go out and do the next thing
yeah right so ideally you're not losing
all of those right but when it comes to
financials of course you need an
accountant
of course you need to be aware of cash
flow
those things are you know our bookkeeper
maybe not accountant a bookkeeper or
cash flow like you kind of have to have
your stuff together a little bit
um
but other than me watching cash flow
making sure that i have enough money to
pay everyone and that eventually i will
get money back from clients yeah
we're not really that savvy
like we don't we don't we don't leverage
money from this person to try and
squeeze that person uh we pay our
our suppliers and our vendors and our
staff right away but we don't get paid
from clients for like three or four
months
like we're just very conservative in a
lot of ways but that gives me the
freedom to be able to say yes to the
client in the meeting
and then later figure out what we're
going to actually do and that's very
very powerful
i love that you
so i love that you push back on the
client i love that you get some options
and ranges i think it's something that
everybody can learn from
uh
how do you feel about free
work uh if you talk about portfolios
that doesn't bother me but when to do it
when not to do it somebody's starting up
they don't have a portfolio where it's
limited or it's not the work they want
to do
when to make the decision say okay this
is worth doing for free versus you kind
of mention it with the three things to
look at yeah what are three things again
portfolio money and happy client
happy client like they love you they
love you love you and they'll talk about
you they'll talk about you you call them
up they always take your call you email
them they respond right away
yeah those people come back those
who presented your business referrals
that's interesting
um the ballpark
probably very little really um
because because the majority of our
businesses repeat okay right so so when
you're in a business where where
where it's not project based and it's
not repeat then referrals are important
yeah so most people who meet us for the
first time meet us because they're
looking for someone online okay and
we're gonna get into marketing later but
they meet us online uh
we do get referrals from people where
someone's talked to someone but there
are a lot of people who talk to a lot of
people yeah there's a lot of people out
there right so the majority of our work
actually comes from someone looking for
us online or maybe being introduced to
us like five or six or seven years ago
and then they leave the company and go
here and take us with them but now we
have this company and this company yeah
and then that person
you know leaves and goes here and now if
we can hold that sometimes we can't now
we have three companies or it's just
year after year after year our best
clients
we work with um you know we work with
for five six seven years
uh there are clients that we we worked
with 10 years ago who disappear for four
or five years and then come back and
they become our best clients and then
they disappear yeah and then they become
our best clients again yeah so it it's
always kind of changing but
uh you know having people
having really great customer service and
again we're getting into that as well
yeah having people like you yeah uh
being able to deliver is really really
important so the three things you're
making money from it it's a good
portfolio piece and you have happy
clients
you want one of them at least one yeah i
mean ideally all three would be sure i
know but but like where's the if if it's
zero it's a walk away if it's three
minutes if it's zero you don't know to
the end though so that's the other thing
if it's zero you know what you don't
know to the end you don't know it's the
end of the project if you've even
there are projects
the greatest of intentions right the
best of relationships you don't have the
budget so you know it's zero on the
budget you're not taking tax checks well
i don't mean zero is in like you're
taking you're taking it for free i mean
like but it's not like oh we got 10
grand
yeah it doesn't hit your margins and as
you get more into it you figure out you
get a you get a better success you learn
quickly for sure but but but so it's
fine so like three is a home run three
or three is a home run zero to three is
that this sucks zero is like you don't
don't don't take it
do you take the one you take the two
you're gonna take if you've got nothing
to do you do you take the one sure
if you have nothing to do
right so everything is an opportunity to
prove yourself yeah right and um you
know i i think it helps to know what
your motivations are yeah to dictate
that like yeah like one of my
motivations is recognition yeah i know
that i live off recognition so i will
much rather do something for free for
someone yeah just to have them turn
around later and say like that was
really good happy client sure happy
client or to hit success yeah uh
having a portfolio
which can be client testimonials it can
be examples of work it can just be
having the logos up on the site these
are the people we work with yeah right
that is
cornerstone to any agency okay right
people want to work with people who have
worked with other people yeah and it
it's a catch-22 when you're starting so
what you start with is just it's just
anyone you can and then you slowly kind
of
remove the bad examples and you get
better examples and better examples and
better examples and yeah and year over
year you work your way up in budgets you
work your way up in experience you work
your way up in value your portfolio
grows
it's just it's just time it just takes
time to do these things everyone i look
up to is 20 years ahead of me and i go i
want to be them but
you know they have 20 years more
experience yep nobody starts i mean
sorry maybe garyvee starts by literally
saying like i'm opening up my doors and
here's my agency and look at how big and
great we are but even within the doors
of their agency
there has to be that ramp up period
there has to be the examples and other
things most of us start and then year
over year over year you grow
awesome so the two main things i'm
taking from it is for pricing
always ask for what their budget is
always give some pushback never just go
into something where where you're in the
dark and quoting on something without
expectations and and don't don't allow
for generalities don't we don't do that
like oh don't worry we have budget you
know and then we go
to something and then we go okay great
you budget 30 grand whether it's 500
bucks or 5 000 bucks or 50 000 bucks you
have a general range and then you quote
against that and then ask yourself
the three questions the filter through
which picking projects
you have to have at least one ideally
two when home run is three
of i'm making good money from this
it's a testimonial piece for my business
it's a happy client yes today we're
going to talk about how to stop
second-guessing your decisions
it's a big one
what's your advice where do we go you
want to ask a question there how do we
stop second guessing our decisions
so
first of all
as an entrepreneur there's no rule book
right you don't know what's expected of
you you don't know what to do you don't
know the right answer you don't know the
wrong answer a lot of times you spend
your time just hoping you're going the
right way right and so really what most
of us have to rely on more than anything
else is our gut okay and so we're told
not to really trust our gut we're told
you know i tend to try to take counsel
with lots of people and i might really
strongly believe one thing but you know
i'll rationalize it or or someone will
say something else but in my gut it's
just going like no like this is the
right answer and what i've learned is
every time where where i'm saying this
is the right way to do it yeah and i
don't listen to that it kills me okay it
kills me in the end so all that said
there's a reason why you wanted to start
your agency
there's a reason that the clients have
chosen to work with you
right there's a reason people are
telling you you're good at your given
craft what you need to do is understand
that the common denominator in that is
you and it's the innate way you you
react it's the the taste you have it's
the work you do it's the things that you
go this is right and this is wrong
and so what i've learned is you have to
be able to trust your gut but most of us
really suppress that most of us try to
try to rationalize it or try to try to
go against it just to be nice or just so
that way more people will listen to you
or more people will like you yeah and so
where do you start you start you don't
start with me actually or anything i
have to say you start with your book
that you wrote you know you start with
your one word and so understanding and
being able to work through your one word
helps you get to that core essence
in my opinion yeah you wrote the book on
it yeah yeah it gets you to your
core essence yeah of of understanding
what is this thing how do i look at this
what am i pursuing what am i going after
my one word is extraordinary and so
there are things that i choose to do
without even realizing it because i'm
always trying to lean to the
extraordinary i don't want things to be
ordinary yeah i don't want things to be
average yeah i don't want things to be
if you can get it from us or get it from
somewhere else why would you pick us
right i want them to be extraordinary
and so that motivates me and that even
when i don't know it yeah so
understanding that one word you know in
our office here uh one of our teams uh
one word one of our team members one
word is passion okay so understanding
that he is always going to look at his
work through the lens of of having a
passion for something a drive for
something a desire for something means
he's going to pour himself into the work
right right someone else is one word in
my in my office is art it's a very
strange one word we thought but we
realized it wasn't art like a picture on
the wall it was when things align so
well that it that the only word to
describe it is like magical it's like
it's like it's artistic how things can
be so perfect and can align so well and
so when he's doing his work and pursuing
his recommendations and trying to work
on behalf of the client he's looking for
that so someone is passion someone is
art mine's extraordinary they're all
living in the same kind of world and so
i'm attracting uh talent and and
staff that align with my values i'm
attracting clients that align with my
values because they want the
extraordinary right and so to answer the
question like how do you trust your gut
how do you make better decisions it's
actually understanding who you are
understanding why people like you why
people don't like you a lot of people
find me loud or abrasive or i don't
think things through long enough or or
you know because i try to come at
everything i think with like a lot of
heart and some people think i could be
more polished or more this or more that
or whatever it is
okay cool some people don't like me i
can't change to make them like me yeah
but what i can do is embrace who i am
embrace my one word how i approach
things and just do more of it be like be
more comfortable sharing it be more
comfortable
uh
owning that and you're gonna attract
more people you're gonna build a better
culture and you're gonna you're gonna
trust your decisions more because you
know like like i take comfort in knowing
that
clients come to work with us because
they like me
okay right they like what i have to say
they like what i have to do they like me
the people i hire
believe the same things i believe
so if people come to work with me
because they like me
they're going to like the people who i
have on my team they're going to like
our recommendations
we're going to deliver a project and
they're going to like the project
right i take comfort in all of those
things aligning
because as i'm making decisions to hire
someone i'm like no no they they need to
click in with us
i don't need to change for them when i'm
making decisions on on pitching for
clients if i feel that connection we
just talked about pricing and would you
do things for free yeah if i
if i feel like there's a great
opportunity this is a great client it's
like sure i'll do it for free of course
i will because we share the same values
and we have the same things but that
only comes from me understanding me and
having the confidence to be able to do
that and so if you work through your one
word if you understand what makes you
you if you understand why people like
you
then you can attract
more of those clients more of those
people and and you can make decisions
with more confidence right
so if i'm just getting started
i've got this big decision in front of
me should i take this path or this path
is it for you come back to
what would the extraordinary version of
mark do or what would make this
extraordinary that helps shape your
decision
i think i have learned to trust my gut
more okay so
so i know that i pursue things because i
want them to be extraordinary yeah and
most of the time that helps me sometimes
it gets me into trouble okay all right
sometimes i over invest in projects that
like i just spend more time and energy
on stuff to make it extraordinary when
no one asked for it to be extraordinary
and no one wants it to be extreme is
that good well your client doesn't want
extraordinary but you want to well it
helps me realize that they're not a
great client for us
right and so i get through the project
and i go why am i working so hard for
this why do i care so much why do i want
it to be so good why do i want these
things and i go oh
but without your advice
but so it's a bad client who doesn't
respect
and you thought they would be great and
you learned along the way that these
guys suck awesome
do you see the action you can take is
you can say you fire the client
okay do you fire the client do you
you know if what they want is is a tenth
of what you actually want to give them
do you
do you just mail in the project and give
them what they want or do you add even
if it's at a loss to you
add it to make it extraordinary like how
do you balance that decision yeah so
you you can only
i i would i would still go all the way
until the client is basically telling
you to stop
but what if they've already told you to
stop but it's not what you want then you
stop you hand them the project
right like we're like yeah you can't
you but they'll say like this is great
they love your vision for what you do
but we beg we beg clients to let us take
it further okay like so so we we did
this project with a client where where
was missing a core component we were
shooting this video
right and we put it all together the
client likes it but it's missing it's
missing a few shots of a people doing a
few things and there's this big hole in
the project like it just doesn't make
sense without it yeah so we go back to
the client say listen client we will
show up monday morning at this place we
will make all of the arrangements and we
will do it for free okay and they're
like
do we really need it and we're like we
need it
we need it because the project doesn't
make sense we will do everything for you
we just need you to call this location
and tell them we're coming by right and
they were like ah you know i don't know
i don't really want to make that call i
don't really want to do that you know i
don't really want to go there like
i can't just show up like we can't just
break into a facility yeah yeah so like
a little part of us dies yeah and we
tell the client like we are willing to
do this just please let us make the
project better well because even though
it's free
it's not free because they have to still
have their team involved somehow
it's not free for them because there's
this perceived thing of like i don't
really want to bug that person right
this work right there's their time even
though you're not charging for it
yeah so i can understand their point of
view right they're like that's good
enough i i had to like we have to see
what you do so a little part of you dies
and then little part of our size and we
wrap up the project we cancel it and you
give them what they want did it make us
money yeah it's no longer an example
piece right does the client still like
us right right like you can't like okay
so now it's immediately not an example
piece right right so hopefully we made
money would you the client still likes
us we've worked with them for many many
years would you then take it and and
tweak it to make it on your own
yeah we do that too even if you don't
like because you want the portfolio
piece and say you know what i'll eat the
cost of the extra whatever so i have a
portfolio in this case we didn't but
you mean like we do go to their facility
you need them right yeah we do that all
the time in cases where you don't
so i just last week i emailed my client
and i asked for four changes to be made
after the project was delivered to fix a
few things just so it would be at my
standard on the website and we are
paying for that and we will give the
client the updated version after the
fact we'll be like hey we met our
deadlines and everything's great but we
noticed a few little things we wanted to
fix right we'll give them that but i pay
for that out of pocket right
everyone there's a photographer who came
and took a picture of me early
and i just won a headshot from my
website
and he wanted to do fancy stuff and like
made me look like i feel like i had like
devil eyes or something it's just really
weird that's what that was his
expression like
i don't really want to put that on my
website as a pro so
he gave me what i wanted but then he
said hey do you mind if i put this up on
my website as a portfolio piece
evan bean like devil is like yeah go for
it man i'm not bold of you i would have
been like no
because i would have trusted your gut
and your gut says i don't really want
people seeing me this way i don't care
about that i just don't want it i i had
a vision in mind for what i wanted and i
got it and then if you want to tweak
something to then fit something else
that serves you and i can be part of
that yeah awesome
yeah we've i mean we've gone so far to
submit like there's a few things we
submit awards for sometimes people think
it's credibility to get awards yeah
we'll submit our versions of stuff for
rewards not the client version
right
right and do you ask the client for
permission you just do it
uh we just do it right okay i hear you
we've only been in trouble once with one
client for and it's only because they
won the award okay and we said great
news right you won the award
yeah we gave them the award we're like
you or this project won the award
thanks just so next time you know yeah
just the next thing you know can you ask
us in advance right and and thank you so
much that we won an award that's great
but you asked us in advance
and we were like oh my goodness i didn't
realize like to be honest i didn't even
think that right who would get mad for
winning an award right and they didn't
get upset right they were like next time
please right right does that make sense
one of the things i think you're really
good at is pushing clients
whether it's uh and like you've gotten
way better at this too pushing them on
what they need in their business pushing
them on the limitations that they have
like you recognize that you're the
expert at this you're trying to help
them accomplish a goal you guys are on
this joint path and because you're the
expert they should listen to you on this
thing you're good at pushing people to
bigger budgets if you feel that it
serves their need better and so
to this theme of making better decisions
and learning to trust your gut how do
you
i think a lot of people have an idea and
they would love to tell the client or
ask the client but they never do it
so how do you get the
the courage i guess to
to trust your gut yeah you hear that
voice you're like ah you know i wish if
i if i had asked them this yeah and then
you you they take away the yes for them
right yeah so so a few things when i was
starting out my career i felt like i had
to have all the answers yeah and now
i've grown very comfortable with this
being exploratory with clients okay all
right so one
remove the idea that you should somehow
have a crystal ball and know how things
are going to turn out when you don't
all right
you know you just you just i can't
predict now when clients say like how's
this going to be i'm like i don't know
right i trust my process i know that
we're very good i know we will get there
working with a client but but i used to
feel that somehow i had to be able to
answer the question that couldn't be
answered because that showed how smart i
was yeah and that's not it's actually
having the confidence to say we will go
through this together the questions you
are asking i cannot answer but trust me
it's going to be like a lot of fun to
get there
it's
having excitement for the work you're
doing
right if you're not excited about the
project the opportunity or the work
clients can get a sense of that
it's
having you know we are very transparent
with budgets we are very transparent if
clients ask any question at all we
answer the question
um we've only ever had one client ever
say like hey let me see the budget
breakdown yeah like the actual like
hours and budget and hourly rate one
client yeah we do like 100 140 projects
a year for the last 12 years and we've
had one client ask for that and we gave
it to them yeah and they said oh gosh i
wouldn't spend money this way so okay
how would you like us to spend your
money
but we're very open
uh and i i believe that the clients
understand that like
like things cost money
uh they cost what they cost if you want
it to cost less we'll pull stuff out
until the project no longer works yeah
if you want the project to be better
and and i say better because spending
more money doesn't always make it better
but
if you want to spend more budget it's
more resources for us that's fantastic
for everybody yeah
but for the most part it's if something
is going to break the project we are
always looking for something that's
going to break the project right every
project has a has like a red flag or or
a linchpin or one core component where
if you like if we do not do this yeah
really really well the project will fail
right and so we are actually just coming
at projects and looking at for like
trusting my gut yeah right knowing how i
would approach it and going ah this is
the one thing that's going to make the
project fail yeah so so for someone like
this could be on the macro it could be
on a big picture we're like
you should even take this client or they
want me to do this website but trust
your gut no no okay but so i'm thinking
like should they want to do this website
but it's actually it's great for me but
it's not even for them like it's not the
best thing that they should be doing i
would do it
or in a in a little mini scenario where
you know you're shooting the video and
you think there should be an extra light
and so you pause and you say hey can we
bring in an extra light yeah where you
you know it might be inconveniencing
them but you know like this is i'm
trying to get the best video for you out
when when you have a idea whether it's a
little tiny thing like that or something
bigger
and there's that voice telling you yeah
say hey i should ask but but it comes
down to will it break the project
right so so if you're shooting and you
want an extra light because you really
want to fill in this side of the face
and whatnot okay but
you are going to sacrifice something
else to make that happen you have a
one-hour window you don't get any more
time so so like but like if it will not
break the project if you can save it
later if you can edit around it if you
can fix it if you can fix the code if
you can rewrite it if you can take a
photo better later
it's not cornerstone
then then
if you can bring it up but don't don't
lose sight of the big picture of
delivering the project sure but if it's
going to break the project you have to
say something okay so that's it so
if you're if it's going to break the
project it's an important decision
you got the voice telling you i should
say something but you're afraid
what do you tell yourself to get in
there
uh there's lots of people like they know
this is the right thing but they're
they're just afraid to what if what if
it's the wrong call like i mean what if
it's the wrong call and the client
thinks i'm an idiot or or i want to do
this and it doesn't work and so they
don't do it but they feel like they
should do it how do you tell yourself so
there's a few things
if you're if you're a little voice in
your head screaming at you in the moment
yeah
and you're not comfortable speaking up
yeah
end the conversation by saying i i need
to go away and talk to my team and think
about this whether you have a team or
not
i need to go away and talk to my team
and think about this i'm really not sure
about this one part of it okay and then
you go away and an hour a day two days
later you come back and you say i talked
to my team about this and we have some
concerns okay i talked to my team about
this
and we can totally do it this way but i
i'm a little bit worried about this or
this so if you don't have an answer
don't fake an answer no say i'm gonna go
think about it and that's part of the
process i used to i used to think i
needed all the answers all the time yeah
and now i've learned that that
most people actually have to take time
to explore things yeah right you have to
you i'm not sure about that and i don't
know why so let me just go away and
think about this let me do some research
let me look at what other people are
doing yeah let me let me talk to um let
me talk to someone on your team okay can
i talk to bill and then maybe and and
then i will come back to you but i'm a
little bit worried about this okay so if
you don't have an answer don't fake an
answer ask more time it's awesome don't
feel like you have to have the answer
what if you have the answer like you
feel like this is the right thing but
you're just afraid
well how do you tell yourself because a
lot of people have that but they don't
they still don't say it it's like what
do you tell yourself so that you say it
do you want to be
i don't like i don't i don't have that
i have that issue in like social media i
don't like to share things and i should
be more vulnerable and i should share
more but in a meeting it's just like
it's just it's to me it's black and
white it's common sense it's right like
so sure but your common sense is not
somebody else's common sense so for me
i'll say if you're 85 sure you're 100.
because you're never 100 sure oh yeah
sorry that that's a great way to explain
it then right so if you're if trusting
your gut is if that little inkling is
there do not suppress it do not say oh i
hope things will work out later that's a
red flag yeah that's some that's and and
you're you owe it to your client yeah to
speak up about something they're not
aware of now i i have seen a lot of
creatives harp on an issue over and over
and over again when the client is just
saying no and they're not listening and
they're just pushing and pushing and
pushing but that's not what we're
talking about we're not talking about
the tenth time you're going back to the
client yeah or you're not talking about
arguing with a client to try and prove
you're right and they're wrong right
this is just if you're sitting in the
meeting and someone's like
let's go left and you're like guys i
think we should go right yeah then then
you need you need to speak up okay
i love it so so takeaways i'm hearing
are one figure out your one word it
gives you a lot more clarity confidence
that's an easy one for me but for
yourself and your team which was
interesting like the people who you work
with you want to know their one word so
you can help them with what they're
doing oh yeah you understand them better
uh two when you work with clients if
they if you don't have an answer don't
fake one and just say you need some more
time and three when you have that little
voice saying
that you got to step up then practice
listening to it and stepping up
understanding your market and your
competition i think is a big thing when
people getting started i don't know what
my market is how do i stack up against
the people i use there's tons of people
doing what i'm trying to do
what's your advice
so first of all it makes sense to start
where you live
local market local market okay right
yes you can expand i i like to think i
want to create the type of company
where someone across the country yeah
would want to work with me they're going
to fly over all those other companies
they're going to pass everyone else to
come and work with me okay that's the
dream yep but but truthfully you're
going to start with places you can drive
to places you can call places you can
work with right so so depending on the
type of agency you run some things have
to happen local some things don't okay
if you're shooting photography for a
website or something it has to happen
local right if you're shooting a video
it tends to be very local right if
you're doing online advertising it could
be anywhere design can be anywhere all
these all these other great things can
be anywhere yeah but what you want to
start with is you want to look at your
local market and the number one uh
conversation i have with entrepreneurs
who are trying to do what i do
i have these calls once or twice a month
they're always saying ah man i really
love the business that you've built how
do i do what you do and then i say oh
where are you located and they say oh um
send them this video seriously i'm in
new england yeah or uh i'm in uh north
dakota yeah or i'm in
where pick pick any place right like i'm
in rural england
and and so it's like well first of all
i'm just lucky that i was born in
toronto right i'm lucky that toronto
happens to be the main economic hub of
canada right right like if you were born
in manhattan yeah
pretty great place to run a business a
lot of competition yeah a lot of money
yeah so if you're thinking about your
million dollar plus business yeah and
the companies you're modeling
consider your market and where you are
at if you are dealing uh you know
if we're down in miami or down in uh
orlando it's not a huge market in fact
there's not like there's sure there's a
lot of lawyers there's
there's a lot of um professionals
medical professionals your businesses
here local still around the area driving
distance oh gosh
like 80
95 of our business so much of our
business is based off relationships
right
really and and how can you build a
relationship with someone if you're if
you're pounding the phone cold calling
them or so if i want to build a business
only on local yeah how big a city do i
need to be in well it depends on the
type of business you want to build and
that's where it's going you know if
you're if you're if you're comfortable
uh if you're comfortable working with
projects
where it's mostly medical professionals
uh or lawyers or realtors or local uh
like those local type of businesses who
need tons of help the window cleaner
right the the person who runs um
uh a construction company right it could
be a 40 million construction company
right it's a construction company
if you love that business if you love
those clients if you love that work then
those businesses are everywhere if you
want to run um
uh the startup for a new vodka company
or new vodka drink
you're probably gonna have to be in like
california or new york or toronto or
montreal or london or paris or like like
if think about the types of companies
you want to work with
more so than the size of the projects
but toronto is how many people
uh in the general area we're about four
to five million we're the we're we're
right we're right above chicago it's a
big city right yeah so so so if i if i'm
in a city fourth largest in north
america if i have a city with with 25
000 people like i'm probably not
building a million dollar business off
of doctors and dentists or lawyers or am
i i mean you'd be the king of that town
right but or the queen's
at some point is there a minimum size or
a city like it needs to have a million
people at least to be able to it depends
right on the type of people you're going
to go after it depends on on the on the
companies that are there right so if
you're if you're building a marketing
agency you're in b2b right you're a b2b
company you're selling to other
businesses so if it's a bedroom
community with a million people and
there's no industry yeah there's no
companies yeah it doesn't matter how
many people yeah if you're in a 50 000
person town and there's only one factory
you're not going to do it if you're in a
small town with a lot of industry or a
lot of companies
you're doing great so if i want to build
a million dollar business and i'm in one
of those sleepy communities
you have to move yeah or you have to
start thinking non-local
okay right so this is the challenge how
do you build businesses how do you so so
my wife's aunt
is um is a really successful
entrepreneur
out of uh roanoke virginia okay it's
it's not a huge market
but she decided or or based on her
experience she's very heavily in uh
involved in technology and i t as it
relates to law practices okay she went
on the speaking tour she speaks a lot
she is the she's as far as i'm aware the
best at what she does for that one type
of company and so when she goes around
she has clients from all around america
right right and they're more than
comfortable to fly over everyone else
yep to work with her right right so she
didn't have to move she didn't have to
move her business she didn't have to do
any of those things because she's
willing to to go out there build the
relationships build the the type of
company she wants to build she's in
physically move but she has to travel a
lot for her work
people have to meet you right right so
so if i if i think okay my my if i'm in
a big city awesome i'm set if i'm in a
small city or town a lot of competition
there so that's what the second half
here right
there
yeah i hear you
if i if i'm in a tiny little community
but i want to build a million dollar
plus business and i recognize okay it's
not going to happen this community do i
start here and then move or i just move
to that new bigger city that i'm going
to build my business in
it it depends on so so starting here and
then moving
if if you're comfortable being the big
fish in the tiny pond
and you can learn make your mistakes
you know now like again video one i
think it was a v2 said like get started
right get started right away yeah so
don't let this be the thing that holds
you back but it's getting started moving
to the city like if i want to my goal i
want to build a million dollar plus
business like you did mark
in in in this space
is it better to start in my sleepy town
and get a couple clients and get some
experience and then trying to transition
that to a bigger city it's like i need
to move to the next biggest city in my
province or state
and then start up there
i i would start in my town and then grow
knowing that this is just this is that
these clients aren't my real clients
that my work is probably not that
transferable right um okay but it's but
this this start right away and so if
it's going to take you four months to
move
what if i move right away like okay i
made a decision who lives their lives
where they're like i'm moving tomorrow
to a place that i've never been to
something i don't know and how do you
find your region yeah but who lives
their lives and i'm going to start a
business like everybody everybody
hems and haws and like right six months
instead of business so but if you're
saying just start what's my best start
the first start is is start local right
but because i'm going to wait four
months to move like what if i said i
would move right away what's my best
start
that's a lot of change for one person to
do so so in this situation someone's
like i'm i'm quitting my job i'm
starting a company i'm moving into a
place i don't know for businesses i
don't know to to a totally new geography
or town right i mean if you're moving an
hour away move okay move you don't need
to move though you can just drive
commute do whatever you need to do
if you're if you're yeah if you're in
new england and you're halfway between
like new york and boston sell into both
places right like just say okay monday
and tuesday i'm going to be in this city
and i'm going to spend the night at uh
whatever at an airbnb or something and
i'm going to hit my meetings and i'm
going to do my thing like you got gotta
hustle you gotta drive you gotta be
willing to go so this is if you're in uh
you know if you're if you're
six hours from the local area that's a
pretty big move well whether you're even
physically moving or not whether so if
you're an hour and a half out of a big
town
whether you decide to go
into that big town and trying to sell
there or into your own local town and
sell where you are
even though it's not that far commute
it's still not exactly where you are
what's the better play like if i want to
hit a million as fast as possible that's
my goal i want to be the next mark
draker
what's my fastest path is it build here
get some revenue get some experience
easier connections or is it like right
away these guys don't get me they don't
get my art like in the big city they
have bigger budgets and go straight
there what's my best path if you have
relationships where you're at start
right away with the plan to move
if if the clients are waiting if the
people are waiting build your portfolio
start right away okay if if it's if it's
starting from zero in both areas and you
have the ability to move right away move
right away okay
cool everything's gonna everything's
based on relationships sure so
so your relationships in your local
little town or wherever you might be
will take you so far right
and that's fine you're gonna learn some
stuff most people will turn their nose
down on it if it's not big enough budget
if it's not good enough if it's not this
if it's not that but again you're going
to start and you're going to move your
way up so if you don't know anyone if
you have no work in your town if there's
a sleepy little town with this or that
or
you know you talk to a business owner
from from
new zealand who's like if i could sell
the sheep i'd be a millionaire right but
all we have is sheep i can't sell the
sheep right i don't know i've never been
to new zealand i don't think that's the
case but that was his attitude so you
gotta move right
or also along your lines of relationship
you can also say
hey do you know anybody in the city
like if you're an hour and oh yeah
outside of new york like
great you may have connections here but
like hey do you know anybody in new york
who might be able to use me or whatever
the next closest big city is
even now like we're not in toronto
no like my office my office is a
marketing from here to downtown toronto
14 kilometers it takes anywhere from
half an hour no traffic to an hour and
10 with traffic right i don't i don't
live in toronto either and you live i
live 55 kilometers from here which is
like miles like 30 miles from your house
to toronto downtown toronto is what
hey hey lucas you just brought lunch
lunch lunch bring it in we got to eat
entrepreneurs need to eat thanks lucas
yeah thanks man
leave it in leave it in leave it in yeah
all of it
including that and this from from your
house to
tomorrow
downtown toronto is what oh uh an hour
yeah an hour and a half two hours if
it's a friday afternoon right so i think
there's a lot of people like they may
not be in the city but they're around
the cities you don't have to go and move
to the city but you're focused on
building up business around here you
would take a local business but you're
not focused on
mechanics and doctors and whatever in
oshawa no oshawa but you're not sure
yeah
right if you know so this really only
applies for the people who are like
who are like three four five hours right
from some place
in in my opinion right if you really
want to be if you have your dream to be
in that place and go and do that thing
like ultimately you have to go where the
money is
if you want to build a million dollar
business
you don't want to do that yeah on
10 000 projects right right you want to
do that on like like i said you know we
have we're a million plus yeah so we do
80 90 100 120 130 projects a year yeah
still a lot of projects yep some of them
are very very small four or five hundred
dollars is a project some of them are
very large 225 thousand dollars is a
project yeah right that gets one project
code one invoice yeah so but you know
we're doing 90 100 120 of those a year
so
you want to be able to not have to have
right 10 000 clients because you can't
give them attention and do all those
other things
talking about competition
so in terms of competition what you want
to do is be able to look two-fold in
your little sleepy town you could
totally crush it right you could be the
best you could be the best very very
quickly
right but you're gonna hit a ceiling
where unless if you have your eyes set
on being the best in america the best in
canada the best in europe the best in
the world wherever it is chances are
those competitions are not going to push
you to be the best that you can be even
when you're starting
so
what i
recommend is look at the people
that you really want to be like right
they're not
the people who are bigger than you are
not your competition
so understand that right you're going to
look at them you're going to we're just
as good as them we could do what they
would do if people would just give us a
chance but they're not giving you a
chance okay so they're not your
competition the people who kind of do
what you do but don't do what you do
they're not your competition either okay
the people who are smaller than you are
not your competition okay your
competition
are
the people
the companies
or even the indifference or the lack of
budget
of the people that you want to work with
why are they not working with you okay
that's your competition right i really
want to work with this type of company
if they are going to the huge agency
you're never going to you're not going
to win that so you have to work your way
into that
right so that's how you look at the
competition you say okay i need to turn
myself into this type of business to
compete against those people and be
better than them
if it's a if it's
if the type of company you want to work
with
do not seem to have budget
your competition isn't any other company
your competition is is a lack of budget
so are you going to win that
are you going to be able to sell into it
how do you convince people to have
budget when they didn't think they had
budget right so so i started and people
get caught up in looking at the
different companies they google their
area they look at who's up and they go
okay let's do a swot analysis let's look
at our strengths and weaknesses and our
opportunities and our tactics or
whatever swat stands for and and uh i
think it's that's strange
i don't know if the t is might be
tactics tactics feels off but i don't
know it might be you might be right
anyway whatever i haven't stressed
threatens threats i haven't done a swat
in 12 years don't do a squat because it
doesn't help according to marc jacob
but but the point is you look at what
everyone's doing and that's great yeah
but
your business is going to be built off
of relationships in your portfolio
right and so if i keep going up against
company down the street for every single
pitch well they're my competition
but if i don't
then they're not
right like don't get caught up in
looking at all these companies
if you're not going up against them if
they're much much bigger than you say
how can i get there because i want their
clients to steal their clients if
they're smaller than you are they
stealing my clients are they nipping at
my toes so so how do you say because our
last part about finding the market yeah
so it's great to have a market but there
might be a lot of competition there too
so maybe you want to move so how do you
assess how do you assess which market to
get into
with what competition is there do you do
you care about the competition do you
just disrespect the competition you feel
you can do it better
uh if there's no competition is that a
good thing we did that for a long time
when we started so so how do you how do
you what's your advice like i'm looking
at a market great i need to go where the
money is
how much does the competition is in that
market
matter for me to have success
as an agency
it only matters if it's bumping up
against you okay that's it but but it
will right i mean if you're bidding on
projects maybe maybe not okay does that
mean even if the competition is i
i i have to be honest i think if i think
back over the years yeah
i couldn't give you a percentage let's
say 80 okay of the projects that that we
pitch or we win or whatever okay they
never get multiple quotes
so that you can then convince them that
they need an agency to work with no
they're looking for someone and they
only had one person to reach out to
they found us or they're working with us
a second time because again the business
is building right or they've moved
somewhere else or maybe it is a referral
right and there are lots of people who
go i've got to go out and get two or
three quotes we're talking to a few
other companies right that's fine um
but
but most people in fact
have re like reach out to a few people
and people don't respond okay they don't
respond like
like they literally don't pick up the
phone and call back within an hour or
two right like you have to you have to
call back with someone now so am i not
concerned about my competition unless
i'm actually bumping up against
competition like don't overthink don't
waste your time just find the market oh
yeah if you do good work you're going to
win yeah
and don't worry about the competition
unless you're getting crushed right like
we there's a whole bunch of services
yeah where i see like there's a whole
bunch of services we offer where we only
have eight or ten clients okay and i go
oh these all these other companies are
doing work somewhere else but
if 100 people knocked on my door could i
handle 100 people right
there's a lot of work out there there's
a lot of opportunity out there so am i
wasting my time by worrying about what
other people are doing if it's
disservicing the people right in front
of me right right now if you have
nothing to do if you have one project
but you can handle 10. yeah if you're
losing all the time right like you keep
going up you're bumping up against
people and you keep losing yeah then you
got to you got to figure your stuff out
right you got to get better you you have
to give it time you have to expand you
have to do all those things but if
you're sitting at your computer at 11
o'clock at night and you're googling
everyone and you're feeling depressed
because these people are big and we're
really small and they're really
established and we don't have anything
and no no like you're wasting your time
they're not your competition for
services that you offer
would you rather be
first to a new market and and bring and
educate and talk to the clients and get
be the first one or would you rather go
to an existing market
and
beat out local competition
i'm not personally an early adopter in
any aspect of my life okay so
you know i i like showing up to the
party late and being better than
everyone else yeah i'm the same that's
that's virgin that's the virgin model is
it okay yeah i guess yeah 100 it's to go
into a market that does it really poor
and do it better than everyone else yeah
okay so key takeaways
you have to go where the money is you
got to be in a market that is big enough
to support you uh and if you're in a
small market look for connections to the
bigger one but also like start here and
scale that to get to where you want to
go
and then for competition
don't worry about the competition unless
you're actually bumping up against them
pretty much
cool we're talking about how to find the
ideal customer for your business
mark what's your advice so first
now that you've worked through all those
other things we talked about you
understand who you are you understand
the value drive you understand your
market you understand your competition
and everything else
it starts with knowing the cert
it sounds so boring i'm listing this all
off and i'm like oh my goodness it's so
boring
it it's like it's really not rocket
science okay it's what type of companies
do you want to work with okay
what value can you drive for them okay
and who's the person in the company
who's actually going to make the
decision okay so how do i figure what
type of company well it's based on your
motivations and your skills okay right
like we used the example last time if
you if you love working with the local
contractor the local construction owner
okay like you know you just love tools
and so you love working with people who
work with tools there's an affinity
there right you're going to have great
relationships great conversations and
then you work with those people okay if
you want to do something that's really
stylized that has a lot of eyes on it
then you're going to want to work with a
big brand or a b2c company or maybe a
startup that's doing an app and you're
like okay i want to get into this market
or this thing but but that's all like
your motivations the type of company you
want to work with because you get
passion and you bring skill and what
have you
but
the real thing is to understand who in
that company you're trying to sell to
okay who has the budget yeah who's
making the decision who has the final
word on it
and you need to meet those people okay
so
a lot of us when we're starting we
overlook things like internal
communications right we think marketing
okay right marketing means that i have
to help this business with advertising
right but there are lots of companies
who need to be better at at winning over
culture and communicating to their staff
and speaking to clients who are already
clients like through inside sales okay
so this is a great way to get in through
hr okay to get in through uh internal
communications if it's a publicly traded
company through shareholder relations
okay and you can get into these places
and you can start to still do good work
okay be a little square or conservative
but you start to do good work you can
win over the clients because there's
less people going after them okay and
then when you do really great work there
they refer you into marketing their free
communications they were free to
outbound things so but you can only do
that if you know the type of company you
want to go after
and you can know how you are going to
get in front of them like where are they
are are they at networking events are
they
online are they reading certain things
are they listening to certain podcasts
okay where are they where are these
people okay are you gonna knock on their
door yep and then
knowing that if you are gonna go to hr
communications what do they care about
if you're going to marketing what do
they care about if you're going to the
business owner the entrepreneur yeah
what does she or he care about
right
and and so the customer
is important to know who are these
people the type of company in the role
but i keep saying what do they care
about yeah right like
like the value you drive them what they
want to do what they want to accomplish
so okay so
so from the top if i'm looking at trying
to find an ideal customer do i start
around shared interest is that what i'm
hearing you say i i've always found that
in my in my selling style yeah which is
to like try to be friends with my
clients to care a lot about what they
have to do i find that i have a lot of
shared interest with a lot of people so
so the two ways could be either one like
i love chainsaws and so i want to go
work with a chainsaw company still
greatchains.com right or some other
company right husqvarna i'm not a big
fan of them but
now if you're watching i totally will
work with you
so but that's one way or
i
love playing
hockey and there's this there's they're
sitting on the bench with somebody who
does it right or your kids are playing
hockey but their business may not be one
that i
super care about maybe maybe you just
like that person right okay so either or
i find it's very helpful for me to
actually be interested in the in the
industry in the business okay so yeah so
like so like as a company we have tended
for whatever reason yeah like like i
like cars i like mechanics i like all
those things yeah so every chance we get
to work with automotive yeah i like yeah
i enjoy it okay now maybe my team
doesn't yeah i don't know yeah i love
entrepreneurs
so we love working with uh you know the
term we use is like owner managed or
entrepreneurial or mission driven yeah
like because these companies like they
have a purpose they they hum there's
like an energy i love it
uh okay i like working with non-profits
what's she eating
hey
you
are eating something that you're not
supposed to eat
i don't know
i'm so used to my dog eating everything
okay you're going to stay here now
okay so so
if i want to get into automotive i'll
just use that i want to get into
automotive i want to be the agency for
automotive i'm not going to just join a
bunch of hockey teams and hope that
somebody on my bench works automotive no
right
or no okay if you just put it out there
you'd be surprised okay great so so i
want to get into
my strategy
okay so
do you want to work for a dealer
think about how many dealers think about
how many people work in dealerships okay
right and
if you know i go to church and i happen
to be like i go to church with a guy
who's responsible for detailing and
cleaning every nissan vehicle at a
nissan dealership okay nissan's owned by
infiniti yeah i can get into that
dealership they're usually dealer
networks once you get into one you can
get into two once you get into your 10.
then once nissan's doing it suddenly
volkswagen because they own multiple
brands yeah so
if that's my version of automotive i
like i really want to work with service
centers i really want to work with the
dealers i really want to be part of that
business yeah that can be automotive
yeah
automotive though is also aftermarket
it's also technology it's also tires
it's also
uh part centers it's all like like if
you like being around car people yes it
is a custom motorcycle shop that to me
is still in that world is it is a car
restoration yeah right so if if you are
looking for these people they are
everywhere okay and yeah they're they're
at maybe your church or friends of
friends uh they're maybe on facebook but
the other thing you can do is
most of these places have dealer
associations yeah
um if you have if you really want to get
into like if you want to be the king of
automotive
maybe take a trip and happen to go down
to vegas when the big thing is you don't
have to have a booth you don't do those
things and walk the floor you know spend
the six or seven hundred bucks to try
and get there really cheap you know do
it cheap when you're there and yeah walk
the floor and meet some people and hand
out a few cards or what have you but uh
but if you think about automotive is
everything related to aftermarket
everything related to
auto sports so any kind of uh auto
racing uh if you think about uh mx like
dirt biking yeah or motorcycles or
anything related to that because i love
mechanics and i can get into it you
think about uh uh
airplanes yeah you think about rockets
like to me it all lives in the same
world i think it's super cool
these people are everywhere and one
relationship turns into two turns into
three turns into four
so if i'm hearing you right it's
figuring out what you have a passion on
that you would love to be in that world
of and now you're gonna bring your
marketing agency knowledge too you're
gonna start by looking at who your
current contacts are who are in that
space but then maybe even saying to your
friends hey i'm i'm looking for people
in the automotive space for sure i want
to connect with someone because when
somebody says they want to market an
agency
so this is the biggest this is the big
big thing right you know like i like
working with non-profits and charities
okay um because i like the good work
that they do right i'm attracted to the
mission i like the nurse i'm attracted
to the mission yeah i like uh automotive
because it interests me i like
custom furniture making i think that's
cool like i think a lot of working with
your hands and stuff's cool we happen to
work with a lot of financial
institutions a lot of insurance
companies a lot of banks a lot of
pension plans a lot of unions
i'm not super passionate about that but
but we're good at it okay and we have a
lot of context there and we do a lot of
good work there and that kind of comes
from we used to and we still are but we
used to be more passionate about the
work
than about the industry we were in so
that's another way to look at it like
like if you love design
and you love
the the creative process of design i
don't know if you really care who you're
working with if you have the opportunity
to do great design okay right now you
might want to work with like like a
drink company or you might want to work
with uh i mean gosh like there's great
they think about american standard they
make toilets and sinks okay level of
design is impeccable okay right like
like there's great design in every
industry so if you love design
then try to find the people who love
design too
if you love a certain industry try to
find the people who have
who are in the same industry as you if
you love horseback riding
and
you're going to go
hang out at the stables with other
people who happen to have money and are
into horseback riding they own
businesses maybe maybe your shared
connection is like jim right or or
barbara who happens to ride horses and
like like it's it's it there's no right
way to go about this
you just have to find what works for you
and start doing it right and don't
question that you're doing it wrong
right like that's the big thing
so as i hear you so once you identify
ideally the market if you're going after
a market
then it's one using your current
connections and your current resources
and the people you know and telling
people at your church or hockey team or
whatever
and then two trying to be involved in
the organizations and the events to be
around like-minded people that's a great
way and and then when you have that kind
this is all to get to the conversation
right right once you have the
conversation
think about what they want and need okay
so if you're speaking with a business
owner they probably care about revenue
they care about profitability they care
about lead generation
right they want to make money yeah
if you're speaking to someone in
communications they care probably about
not being misunderstood
about following process
uh about
speaking to the the rational side of
things but also maybe some emotion if
you're speaking to someone in marketing
they care about the brand they care
about the feeling they care about
probably still lead generation and other
things you're speaking someone in hr
they care about people all right how do
these people know this how do they
understand it how do we do health and
safety how do we recruit people how do
we keep people
so there are all these different
departments and they have all these
different needs and it's always the same
system no matter what you want to tweak
what you're saying and and how you're
approaching it and you can ask them if
you don't know you don't want to don't
don't say what is keeping you up at
night right right like don't say like
what are you worried about okay ask them
what areas of their business need help
okay
right if you're speaking to someone in
hr
and they say
we really need help like we're losing a
lot of staff
turnover is really hard
there's a problem
that a marketing company a really smart
agency just better communications you
can help them with that right you can
help them with that challenge by
recruiting better people by having them
fix their culture by helping them draft
better copy to recruit better people by
potentially communicating more
internally like it might be just like go
have more company barbecues what role is
that of a marketing agency to tell
someone to have better company barbecues
but if that's the problem they're having
and even if i'm not an event company and
even if i'm not going to make any money
off if that's the answer then i should
give them that answer
because then they can try it and then
they will trust me and then i will be a
partner and then i can help them with
other areas of their business right
i've got a expression called the chief
goal officer oh i like that you have to
be the chief goal officer do you
understand their goals and you know how
you can help them yes that's your first
part of understanding what are their
goals be the chief gold officer first i
don't even know if most people know how
to articulate their goals because the
goal is the answer and what they know is
the problem and i do this with my team
okay let's talk about it because you're
not going to say hey what are your goals
and how can i help like that's not a
great challenges okay so so what like
three questions how do i get this how do
i get to understand somebody's goals
with somebody who's in my market could
be an ideal customer for me
what am i asking them
so this isn't my question and i don't
even know if i really use this because i
always change my wording okay i'm
talking to but here's the essence of it
yeah i didn't invent this i heard this
from someone else who's really smart
what is
something that should be easy but it
isn't okay
in your business in your business yeah
but you can ask this as a manager you
can ask this to anyone right like what's
something that should just be like
really really easy to do okay but it
isn't yeah right that's something that
can be fixed okay that's one um
is something holding you back from being
the company
that you should be okay
again i don't ask that but i ask a bunch
of questions for it i say like what do
you stand for and okay and what are you
fighting for and what are you fighting
against what do you believe in and like
i ask all these general questions but
that's the best
okay the essence of it
is is really like what's holding you
back from being the company you should
be okay not the company you want to be
that's aspirational and that's fine not
the company you are today
the type of company you need to be the
type of company you should be what's
holding you back right there's a
challenge there and that might be
marketing communication staffing
operations lack of funds lack of money
it could be anything but something is
there it's always there yeah
i think the third question and i usually
coach my clients on this is that change
is hard okay so the question i have
asked my contacts
is
is the company actually willing to and
ready to do what they have to do to
change
right and because if i'm working with
the business owner
then it's actually their team or their
company or their circumstance it's
holding them back it's gonna be really
hard to change yeah do you wanna lead
this do you wanna spend the next 18
months or a year or whatever it is doing
it yeah
and if it's someone mid-level or kind of
junior it's like
is is are there people above you really
willing to actually do this we work with
so many people who are like on fire
right they're like i can't wait to come
in there and change the company and then
and they have all these big ambitious
plans and we quote all these things out
and we plan all these things they're
like i didn't get approved or it never
went up or or it gets watered down
because no one really actually wants to
change okay i like to work with
companies that want to change yeah right
because i can help them like please just
let me help you
do what like let me do what i do and i'm
going to help you
and if i'm not helping you then you're
not going to work with me you're going
to fire me right so just let me come in
and help you please please let me help
you that's what we do most of the time
so
uh i know it sounds funny like i'm like
begging but but really
you need to be courageous you need to be
willing to make change you really really
need to work at it so will they do that
and whatever the other two questions
no i don't know i like it i like it i'm
thinking about the process and there's
one piece that feels missing which i
wanted to ask you about so
you know from the beginning i'm thinking
about what i love what issues i love the
type of phone to work with so if i pick
automotive awesome my next step is i'm
going to ask everybody in my network
see if anybody's involved in automotive
somehow or ask if they know anybody in
automotive and i'm going to go to any
local automotive events yeah and try to
participate so i'm known when i have a
conversation
i'm asking those three questions to
learn more about them once i've found
the ideal yeah
there is a middle step there that you
are missing which is which is okay so so
if i'm asking the people what their
challenges are yeah i'm assuming i they
have invited me in to talk about
business right right now what if they
haven't invited me exactly what if what
if the person in my church says yeah you
should really talk to frank yeah i'm
gonna connect the two of you guys you
have a great conversation
then but even bringing it up that this
is what i do
like
you find the person in your church in
your community who is in that industry
yeah we know i'm watching let's grab
coffee so so
how does that work
i say let's grab coffee we should talk
but here's but why what why here's what
i do oh i'm super interested in what you
guys are doing okay i have a few
questions i'd really love to run by you
and are you talking about what your
business is no i'm saying these these
are the excuses okay not excuses these
are the reasons so okay so yeah there
has to be a reason for someone to give
you time so uh i'm a new company i'm
really interested in learning more about
what you do and i and i and i'm hoping
please if you will will give me an hour
of your time so i can ask you some
questions okay so if that's the case
then you go in and you don't sell them
you just ask them really smart questions
okay and this has happened to me by the
end they're like wow i haven't even
thought of those things that's great we
should we should totally get together
and that's fine or
um hey we should grab coffee because
for me because i'm very relationship
based i'm like you seem like the type of
person that i actually want to be
friends with okay
i tell people that like okay you ever
met someone where you're like this
person's pretty cool yeah like i would
just like to learn more about them so
just go meet that person
right i had someone who used to work in
my company who said
you know i don't have to be friends with
my clients i have enough friends i need
to be professional to them okay and i'm
like
not not in my confidence
yeah right and and yeah there's a place
for being professional place we're being
friends but when i was able to actually
flip them around like six months of me
coaching and coaching coaching they're
like wow okay no
there is a value like i was totally
wrong before there is a value
to caring about people and getting to
know people
and spending time with them and all of
those things okay so so if you know that
susan is at your church but you don't
really know her you kind of know her
face but she's in
the automotive business and could be a
potential client for you walk up to
susan and be like hi susan so like at
church at the end of the church you're
gonna find her yeah and i'd be like i'd
be like i just found out that you're an
automotive yeah i think that's really
really cool what did what
i'm sorry for ambushing you what did you
do right oh cool your
senior vp of blah blah or whatever yeah
i'm like that's that's really cool
this is going to come out of nowhere can
i take you off for coffee i know this
seems weird but i'm a new company i'm
getting into this area i'm super
passionate about this stuff i'm not
trying to tell you anything can i take
you off for a cup of coffee and ask you
a few questions okay all right
nobody says no to that right like if
they say no to that then i would be like
okay i don't
this probably isn't someone i want to
work with that's awkward right sure but
you're in church right or you're at the
hockey game or you're
or you're wherever you are or it's aunt
betty happens to be the nephew of
someone who's this or that right that's
how life works
i love it i think the thing the only
thing that's now maybe running through
people's minds are
i don't want to say my new company i
don't want to i want to show that i'm
seriously embrace it no totally embrace
it yes but explain why
i agree but yeah when i started my
company i i i was six months in and i
was about to go bankrupt and i hired a
business coach
and the greatest thing that my business
ever said to me it was just a bit of a
confidence boost he's like you're really
likable guy mark i was like i am like i
kind of think i'm a jerk and i'm very
black and white and i'm very blunt and
he's like no like
you're like you're likable like like
people like you they want to help you
they want to work with you and he said
go take this client that you just got
so at the time we got referred from a
friend into canada's largest bank
one tiny person at one tiny part of
canada's largest bank and we only got it
because of a friend gave it to me like a
gift you knew we were going bankrupt
he's like here here's something for you
my coach said take that person out for
lunch and explain your situation explain
you just started your company
you have a wife you have a kid who's
four months old
you really just want to help people out
is there any way that they could see to
refer you to anyone else in the company
and so i was like oh god i was super
nervous i called them up shaking i asked
them out for lunch
and they're like yeah we could totally
grab lunch together and then i drive all
the it's like an hour and a half away i
drive all the way there we're going out
for this like swiss chalet lunch you
know uh anyway so i take them out for
lunch and i and i basically it's very
awkward we go through the lunch meeting
and finally i say listen
the reason i want to take you out new
company right this is this is my journey
this is what i want to do with people i
would really appreciate anyone else and
i said oh well we'll see what we can do
and this and that they're being very
polite but like two weeks later they
refer me to someone named greg skinner
who was kind of downtown toronto got it
and that person was my client for 10
years but so you also ask for referral
in that meeting if they know anybody but
if you know that they could do it they
were already my client right like i'd
done one really tiny thing for them and
but but i went out for lunch i admitted
where i was i didn't try to pretend to
be anyone else i was i still i still had
to go pitch that right person i still
had to win the business but would you do
that in the first meeting with susan at
your church would you pass your referral
totally okay so so if i got it
you find
shared interest what you love doing you
love cars awesome now i'm going to ask
everybody on my local network who knows
somebody who's in cars or is in cars and
i'm going to go to every local event
around cars to be a part of the
community sure and expose myself
to if i find somebody i'm going to ask
them for coffee i'm going to save a new
business i want to pick their brain
you're not trying to pitch anything
you're just trying to get to know them
better because i want to work with
friends
at the meeting i'm going to ask the
three questions
that we went over we'll show them on
screen because i forgot them but they
were great
and at the end and then at the end
i'm asking
if my business sounds like anything
interesting is there somebody you know
who might be a fit for what i'm doing
if if you're comfortable you can always
do that after okay like if you're
starting a relationship it's not like a
window right so afterwards you can send
me emails thank you so much for the
conversation i really thought about it
it was really meaningful yeah and always
have a follow-up you totally changed
myself by the way if you could see clear
to refer anyone to me it would be so
much to me got it right like you always
have a feeling thank you right what what
what is our issue with asking people i
don't like to ask people for stuff yeah
i don't want to be bothered sometimes
yeah so i had to get over that yeah i
didn't i also didn't used to want to ask
for the business eventually you have to
say are we getting started on this
project
or how much will it cost right or how
much is your budget or like like we have
to get comfortable asking how much will
you ask in this in the meeting itself
versus the thank you email after
um it depends on the way the
conversation is going but i typically
i i typically show up to these meetings
and don't talk at all and i just listen
let's listen and i walk out no i and
then i walk out i'm like
i lost my opportunity right like someone
who was a little bit more direct would
have said
perfect
now let's talk business and you're the
direct guy
i know i know and and i so let's imagine
how hard it is for people watching
didn't then do it but i watched someone
do it mm-hmm and let me just like i know
i know we're going really long here but
i watched someone do it once
where i was sitting in a meeting with
them and we were having this coffee and
and literally the person said
and this is this is someone who's
working for me she goes
we're a really good company we're just
shifting into this stuff and we're still
figuring some of stuff out yeah but we
really care right and everybody who's
working with us right now is someone we
care so much about because we cannot
afford to lose them okay and so i want
to know in the next few months how we
can work together more okay uh what have
you got coming up okay and i was like
and they're like oh um wow i guess we
have these three or four things should
we talk she's like yeah let's talk okay
and so and that stuck with me i never
had the guts right to do that
and but you know now i'm willing to say
like
what's what's the worst thing they're
gonna say like we are in if i'm asking
the person out to ask them some
questions yeah i wouldn't do that right
right but you might in the thank you
email that i have my words thank you
emails or i might even phone them up
afterwards and say i'm sorry i might be
taking too much of your time okay
what i like to do
is i like to share my intentions okay
right we just want to help people okay
why won't more clients in your industry
right let us help them right we think
that the industry is really broken and
weird right why are people wasting so
much money right right and like i i ask
them these questions that get them
thinking right and it may apply to them
or may not yeah um
and then by the end if if we're
comfortable for follow-up coffee i might
say do you think i need a referral to
someone your company do you think you
would be the right person to talk to
about these types of things if we were
to make it work together um do do you
think your company has budget for the
type of stuff that i'm talking about
because i don't really know if they do
right these are also very soft questions
right
right and ultimately
it's okay to ask them yeah
if you ask over the line
and you're being too direct yeah um for
selfish reasons
you'll kind of turn them off but but
that's still not the end of the world
okay like i always
think it's better to just ask
just ask
i love it if someone says no it's like
no right like if you're asking for the
right reasons right just ask and as soft
as in the email after and if and if you
work your way up to in the meeting
itself for sure how to build a brand
that gets noticed
what do you think what do you got for us
so here's here's the the the good thing
and the bad thing grabbing marketing
agency yeah your marketing agency yeah
you should be you should well the bad
thing is it has to be really really
really good right super high standards
right you're being judged on it
uh we find that weight
i find that way crushing like right like
i'd rather not do something right than
do it badly right you can't let that
stop you right the good thing is you're
a marketing agency so you should be good
at this right like if you're a creative
agency then your brand should be really
really creative right and because that's
what you're good at right and if you're
a website company you should have a
great website yep great portfolio of
work uh if you're uh you know an
analytics or lead marketing type company
then your site can be a little bit more
basic but but i would think that you'd
be leveraging really great analytics and
lead generation and you'd be killing it
and yeah crushing it in terms of people
coming in yeah so
really when you're building your brand
for yourself the biggest struggle that
most of us face is
uh actually like what to grab onto
okay so
so for me and and maybe others face this
as well
in marketing
is is most of my
ideas and recommendations are based off
of these little like seeds or core
truths or little little like
you could look at something and there
could be all these different ideas you
can have okay you need like something to
grab onto it's like really hard to
explain i can hear a story you know if
i'm i'm talking to an applesauce company
right i don't get really very passionate
or interested in applesauce okay but if
i hear a story about the fact that the
recipe uh comes from a grandma that's
this and this and this that would be
that like you know the grandma used to
make it for the grandchild the
grandchild grew up to start this
applesauce company that would be it
seems obvious but that would be like one
of these like oh we can grab onto
multi-generational we can grab onto
grandma's eyes we can that's the client
right but when you're working on
yourself right you can do anything right
it's like when you're working with a
client you're learning about them you're
taking this in you're seeing it from the
outside and all these little ideas are
coming up and you're going you're going
we can do we can do this we do this this
is super fun because you're exploring it
right and when it's yourself it's really
hard right it's really hard to see it
from the outside it's really hard to
know what's good enough and what's right
and what's wrong uh and and to be honest
most most really great advertising
agencies there's really great marketing
agencies creative agents have terrible
marketing themselves
and so what we do and what a lot of
people is that a good thing that's a bad
thing does it matter it's a terrible
thing but if they're all great like who
cares
no
it's like no
but like although marketing agencies
have crappy marketing themselves doesn't
matter then like they've had tons of
success well it's good for you because
you can have better marketing and steal
the market share the reason that they do
it or it doesn't matter though or like
it's based on relationships or or your
brand is the work
not what you do internally i'm just i'm
just asking where i'm going with this
yeah
not where i want to take it yeah
i'm not sure i like your ideas
are you the expert where i'm going with
this is okay so you've done your one
word yeah you know what makes you you
you know your essence you know what
clients value because we know our market
yeah yeah right like we're working with
we're working down yeah we're working
down here right so by the time you've
hit this point
you need to create a brand for yourself
that represents
the feeling and the essence
of all of those things okay so if i'm
uh if if my one word is like my wife's
one word is strength or strong
right so if she were the entrepreneur no
matter what she was going into
that brand should speak to
strength or it should be strong she
could she could start a kid's daycare
but we are going to create the strongest
most well-rounded children possible
right right so so on the agency side if
she was creating an agency right
strength yeah and being strong
strong-minded strong-willed pushing
people uh i start to think about
different color tones that that falls
into they better be strong colors not
soft colors okay they would have strong
uh
fonts not weak fonts they have strong
photography not weak photography it
starts to play into it the way you
explain the work your portfolio what you
do yeah
better be strong mind's extraordinary
yours can be passion it can be art it
can be believe it can be anything you
want right but but that is the core of
your brand because
your brand is really nothing more
than um a visualization of what you want
people to feel about you the way you
answer the phone is part of your brand
right because that's nothing more than
how you want people to perceive you and
feel about you the the way that your
documents look
right like i
it really bothers me like we have a
certain header on our documents that
have project number it has date that's
version history it looks super clean
okay right like it's important to me
that art like if you write send over a
word document right to my team that
bothers me when it doesn't fit into that
because it's extraordinary
yeah but it's mostly like like
everything should be clean enough that
you would want to release it to the
world right like it shouldn't have
formatting issues like that bothers me
it maybe doesn't bother someone else
yeah
but to me being precise
and being effective and efficient is
part of being extraordinary okay right
and so and so if you're sloppy yeah you
can be the best
marketer or a person in the world but
you're not going to be sloppy at fanta
right like that really
that really bothers me so so that also
has to feed into our brand we have we
have like a no-nonsense brand okay we
have a black and white like like
literally our brand colors are like
black white and orange like it's just
like it's a black and white brand me too
hey i like my shade of orange better
f730
7300
yeah but uh
it's it's that yeah you can like you can
go into all of those things but building
your own brand is worth it yeah and it's
worth it because
if you're one of the big agencies you're
literally relying on your reputation in
your name
right if you're like if we're thinking
about really big agencies if you're
mccann
right you're you're relying yeah on your
work of course but they've been around
for 40 or 50 years right if if um
if you're van or media vayner van der
meter vayner vaynermedia
right like like i'm sure i i've been on
this website we've looked at it it's a
good website okay right it's a good
website of course it is but from a brand
point of view it's him right like like
like his his attitude his essence his
signature falls into the brand the black
the white the colors and everything
about it is the brand i don't even think
they have a portfolio i'm not i'm not
sure but i don't even think they have a
portfolio what do you think about
personal brand versus logo
like we're building around the logo not
about the face yeah so
you know i don't i don't wanna i don't
everybody has their own way to arrive at
the work that they do so for alright
let's help me make a decision yeah i'm
starting do i make it about me and have
my face and my signature and a close-up
or do i make it about the logo and the
company that i'm trying to build
when do i pick each one yeah so if you
want to build a million dollar company
it's built around you but it isn't you
okay
okay should i so are you saying to build
a million dollar company it has to be
around the logo and i'm a piece of it
but it's not my face and i have people
under me
well brand the you're building your
brand is more than your logo right so so
it's it's
from so think about your instagram
profile is it is it your face or is it
your logo
that's what i think of like a personal
brand versus a business brand i don't
know if i have an answer for you because
i even struggle with that right like i
can turn to you and say like like i i
run our fanta account as my personal
account because to me
i'm not just at work i'm all over the
place and i did that for a long time and
i really enjoyed doing it and then my
team came to me and they're like that
should be your personal thing why are
you sharing why do clients care what
your kids are doing and i'm like yeah
but this is me right fantasme and fantas
all of you too but but this is this
account is my eyes of how i come to work
and how i live my life and the stuff
that we do
and then they're like no no you
shouldn't do that that's wrong
and so i stopped for
maybe a year
and then i went back to them and i was
like that's stupid i don't care i don't
care what the rules are right i enjoy i
i don't want to start a marc drager
instagram account i have no interest in
doing that okay all right fantasme i'm
fanta yeah i have a team yeah we do lots
of stuff
maybe clients like me like don't follow
me if you don't like what i'm sharing
that right right to me
you're past a million dollars in revenue
now you've got how many people on your
team
full-time people 12 full-time people and
then freelancers on different projects
freelancers um
and the the instagram account is called
life at fanta yeah because your logo is
a thing yeah but then you're posting a
mix of your personal stuff and projects
and thought leadership is what you've
got some stuff in too right of like
here's what happened but here's your
take on it yeah and that's that's that's
what i've played with a little bit but i
wish that i had more courage to do okay
and that's what i'm gonna do okay that's
gonna do more like like really i i just
treated it however i wanted and i loved
it yeah and everybody seemed to like it
someone told me i was breaking the rules
and it's not appropriate and a real
company wouldn't do that okay and now
i'm like well i don't really care and
that is um
that is what having the brands about
like that attitude of that story of
being like this feels right to me i'm
gonna do it anyway you guys break the
rules yeah that's what your brand should
be so well more for a real breaking
brand like you want to work with
ambitious
companies so you need to reflect that if
your if your core value was like
you know something
boring i don't know well steadfast yeah
exactly right
then that's that's security right then
it's a different yeah right
so but like so so like in that example
like
if if you're if you're a design company
yeah right i keep going back to design
because there are a lot of really design
based marketing agencies yeah and
there's a lot of lead generation based
marketing agencies or whatever it is but
if you're a design company and you're
trying to decide what you do with your
with your instagram it's like share
whatever inspires you right share
whatever's happening share your work
share whatever you can share but but
just have it come from the heart have it
come from your one word have it come
from a place of truth
and if people like it great and if they
don't that's fine too right like that's
that's what marketing is about it's not
about trying to trick people into buying
something that they don't want or liking
something that they don't want it's
literally sharing the best version or
essence of what
is true to you
so when you're building your brand as
your agency if you are a one-person shop
yeah
maybe you want may not want to represent
yourself as one-person shop maybe you're
going to be afraid okay because it'll
turn off really big clients and it'll
endear you to smaller clients right
right and so so you know are you trying
to fake it till you make it or are you
just going to say like this is me and
this is what i do and this is what i
believe
like there's this line i don't know who
said it and i've heard it on a podcast
but like specificity is the heart of
narrative okay it's like a really
academic
yeah i like it but
whatever i noticed it most is in comedy
so in comedy i'll watch a comedian let's
say that we have
a black
you know an african-american a black
female canadian
right um
a comedian not canadian comedian
comedian yeah we have an
african-american female comedian who's
talking about her very personal things
yeah right in marketing yeah we would
say oh well well she's only going to
identify with only people who are like
her will identify with her story okay
but the truth is she's really funny and
she's really meaningful and i really
like where she's going i really like
what she's doing because she's being so
true and specific to her voice and her
tone yeah if we can be more like that
yeah as brands and not say oh
we want to we want to approach
we want to approach the the southeast
asian market yeah oh we really want to
go after this market and do this and
make these people look like these people
they have to be represented yeah
but real stories of real people that are
very specific are endearing to a lot of
people right and it turns off the people
that it needs to turn off that is
marketing that is branding that's what
if you can do for your company the
agencies who go like like
hot stuff yeah they're doing good work
but mostly they're courageous enough to
do this stuff
i wish i did it earlier
i wish i didn't know
better
how to go from 1 million to 5 million
that's the next that's the next
that's the next series um so i'm just
trying to track back now to what we've
talked about i mean it starts with
understanding this is a this is your
company has to be based off of what you
stand for so if you're going to your one
word and then bringing that to the
business as opposed to just figuring out
a one word for the business but like
it's a personal thing that you bring to
the company
um
i'm i forgot the second point because we
dove into personal branding versus the
other one but there was another key
piece we were talking about
if you're even more lost than i am in
the like because i'm so focused on what
you're saying that i i lost the track of
where we're going like first is find
your find your brand
find your one word
uh bring that to the work that you're
creating everything you do oh this is
what i'm everything at least
everything that you do is a great
philosophy but from a branding how i see
it as everything that touches a customer
so your letterhead the customer
experience your website everything that
touches the customers right but like how
you sit in your office may not touch the
customer but you may want an
extraordinary chair and you should have
an extraordinary chair so it's like
there's a lifestyle and a
operations like how you deal with your
website developer may not touch the
client but it's important for the
business more like how to build it up
ops versus branding so like figure out
at least how i'm thinking about it one
figure out what your one word is and
then how you bring that to every single
piece
of anything that touches the customer
and then customer facing you have to
touch it um
yes
the last thing quickly i just want to
touch on is
how much in our last video we talked
about
customers finding who the customer is
and creating
uh
a way to attract customers to us but as
a very like i'm out there doing the work
meeting people yeah approaching and
we're going to get into lead generation
and marketing okay so but this is more
like brandon i want my brand i want my
brand to stand out
i'm sharing thought leadership content
so and so here's where you're struggling
with it there's a difference between the
tactics that you do and the brand that
you have yeah i'm just where do you
think people there's a difference
between okay i'm just gonna have a great
brand and i'm gonna pay attention to my
stationery my instagram and my website
and it's it's a
yes it's a breathing thing that will
evolve but it's a one-time thing as
opposed to like thought leadership that
it's an ongoing
you telling narrative but thought
leadership could be a cornerstone to
your brand or not it could be so how do
you make the decision versus what we
talked about last video those are
tactics right so but the tactics of
we'll see the next video we're doing the
next video
i'm not spoiling the answer here guys
this is a ten part series one let me
just look at this now look hold on we'll
pause yeah this is all walls say it keep
all this keep going keep going next is
uh lead generation and sales we're going
to get into tactics we're ending this
video here
[Music]
actually no
hold on so we combined a bunch of them
so i had brand broken into brand brand
and brand okay and we we've combined
everything what's the next video
[Music]
you're killing me you're killing me man
i'm killing you
[Music]
we need to have like awkward silence
music or something yeah we'll just we'll
just go to tactics next and then tactics
well what you said we're always like oh
that's tactics and that's next great
what is he wanting
she's bored she doesn't want to build a
marketing agency but for people who want
to build the market this is this is the
mark drager built fanta i keep wanting
fanta media built fanta
two million plus in revenue
with 12 people full time a whole bunch
of freelancers around him and and i want
to suck out of his brain how he did it
to help you guys do it too
if you want to build a market ninja this
is a series pay attention to we're on
episode seven you should have said that
seven episodes go watch all the other
ones today we're talking about marketing
tactics
what do we need to know about marketing
tactics mark draker
are you gonna ask a question that's my
question that's not a question okay
great we talked for 15 minutes about
what we're going to talk about and you
lead with we're going to talk about this
go marketing tactics okay listen we
ended our last video on this huge
cliffhanger insane cliffhanger
talking about
should somebody focus on the branding
and the thought leadership and like i'm
gonna be an expert and i'm gonna i'm
gonna bring people to me i'm gonna be a
magnet or i'm gonna focus on going out
and being a networker and using my
connections and going one to one to
meeting people right and so yeah both
can work right but like how do i make
the decision as to there's tons of
marketing tactics of course there's any
books everywhere anything can work so
like and it all can work and that's
overwhelming so as an entrepreneur how
do i then find a tactic that will work
for me so i can build a million dollar
business of course mark draker okay so
what you want to start with yeah
is understanding the two or three ways
people will be introduced to you
okay okay so so
you need to try and get yourself in
front of people
who don't know you
and
okay so let's start with the hardest
thing people who don't know you yeah and
don't even know that they need you okay
do i even want those people that's
really hard right do i want to convince
advertising well we talked back before
about
i don't know how to i don't know how to
close being early to a market versus so
i'm saying it's the hardest okay okay so
maybe i should rephrase i said you want
to okay that's what exists okay people
who don't know you and don't even know
they need you is hard people who don't
know you
but are looking for your services
is pretty easy okay people who do know
you and are looking for your services
like the best heck right that's amazing
right right so when you're starting when
you start thinking about this way yeah
uh you can start to think about the the
tactics that feel right to you okay if
you are an introvert yeah who does not
like to talk to people yeah who will
never stand up on stage yeah never be a
public speaker not very fond of social
media there's still a place for you in
this world like
you know you can still grow a great
agency but you but but being the thought
leader who is standing up on stage and
speaking panels is not going to help
it's not going to help you you're not
going to be good at it you're going to
hate it okay right so so once we
understand these three levels right the
people who don't know you don't know
they need you
you can reach them through like an
awareness campaign through an
interrupted facebook campaign
you can go and speak at um at an
industry if you're good at this you can
go speak at an industry
um
you know a conference for doctors where
you can teach them about new business
and i never thought of that right the
next level down the people who don't
know you but are searching for your
businesses right this is where the
tactics of getting in front of these
people where are they are they going to
google do you want to do adwords or
pay-per-click and drive them to a
landing page and introduce you it's a
pretty good way to generate leads and
kind of get into that do you want to do
a
facebook
campaign where you're actually
advertising it's a pretty good way to
get in front of those people or
are there more roundabout ways you know
are they people who who are interested
in marketing and learning about
marketing but don't know that they need
a marketer yet and so is being a
youtuber something that's going to
connect you is right is doing uh social
media posts something's going to connect
to you is um starting or being connected
to your the american marketing
association and being involved with that
chapter something that's going to get
you there is it sponsoring events or
awards right so there's a million ways
how do i know what's right for me it's
it's based on you and your skill set and
what you're good at does my personality
type i know you're huge in the
myers-brigg and you have everybody on
your team demyers brig
and you're a what i'm an intp what am i
uh
he emailed it to me that was an e no
you're not an e i was an e you're an e
no i wasn't i was what you thought i was
but i was an e not an i i intj
that makes sense oh an entj yeah maybe
he's emotional i'm more emotional than
no it's extroverted that's right oh
extroverted no that's not true i'm eye
yeah there was one though that you
weren't sure on about the emotional
caring versus
okay whatever we'll figure it out we'll
flash on the screen here it is this is
what i am good okay don't worry about it
forget it forget it will you find this
now you wanna stay live on camera no no
i wanna i wanna get to like it doesn't
matter what i am no no but i have it
right here
hold up wait for it are you ready oh you
said you sent me an image
and the image isn't in the email and i
wrote back wow that's amazing i guess
but i thought you were this is for you
now mark you're an inf you're an infj
perfect
you know what that means anymore it
doesn't matter i nfj so you love
you love personality tests especially
that one
everybody on your team does it
uh it's what you recommend for
entrepreneurs like find your one word
and find your myers-briggs so does that
apply to
does your personality type like i'm
trying to give value to the people
watching yeah
there's no no no no no no
how do we figure it out like what what
am i besides like what are you good at
okay but like is there is there is there
something else can i do a personality
test and then because i'm this i'm more
geared towards doing this kind of work
like you said introverts shouldn't
go on stage
you know i'm an introvert
when i go on stage but
is there anything i can learn maybe
maybe i'm piling down the wrong creek
i'm just wondering if there's anything
i don't know i just want to find
a way for for people who are struggling
to identify the thing because they may
not even know what they could be good at
like maybe maybe facebook ads is the
thing but they haven't tried it yet and
so they'll say i'm not good at this but
like
what do you need to be good at facebook
ads you need to be very analytical so
you wanna you wanna play to your
strengths right so how to find my
strengths so
is it personality type is going to tell
me it's not going to tell me yeah
personality will certainly but where we
started with the type of company that
you want to build back to episode one
right back to episode one yeah right
like if if you are a creative agency
yeah
then and and when we said hey when
you're building your brand it better be
a creative brand yeah you want to find
marketing uh channels that allow you to
express your creativity
right so sponsoring an event yeah
where you can actually put your work up
on display in front of everyone and wow
people with how creative it is right is
a great tactic yeah right but it's not
if you're an analytical company right
for an analytical company you could help
that event
invite more people but unless you stand
up and do a case study and you're like
oh guys let's stop the event right
we improved you know we improved uh
ticket sales by eight percent people
were like who cares right right so
that's not going to be a great thing but
but uh business uh intelligence and
analytics i spoke i spoke
at a government business intelligence
analytics conference right where one of
my clients insisted that i come and help
you remember that i was so out of my
depth yeah uh you know it was police
departments talking about this and this
and i came from marcom and i'm like okay
well this is government and it's all
very technical but i was still
introduced to eight eight or ten people
i mean there were 100 people sitting at
the conference little local thing put on
by the business bureau or whatever but
so so if if you are
uh leaning more towards legion and
analytics yeah then you're going to want
to go towards case studies you're going
to want to maybe try and do like a
sponsored post you're maybe going to
want to do blogging you're going to
maybe want to just allow create
areas and go to places
where people could put that work on
display if you're more creative
maybe you want to do behance maybe you
want to do pinterest maybe you want to
do what's the instagram behance behance
enhance is a it's a community it's a
portfolio community where designers can
go and power okay put stuff okay
lots of people go there to to source for
the companies for yeah okay specifically
uh maybe you want to go to your local
art gallery and you want to actually
print
you actually want to print your work and
you want to put it up and you want to do
a pop-up let's try i want to double down
on this
what personality testing we're going to
double down sure let's see how it works
mars breaks let's go letter there's this
either or for each letter right yeah
let's go letter by letter great so
you're assuming that i have it like
really well memorized absolutely you
guys love it i love it we'll go letter
by letter and give me
my best marketing tactic for each letter
that's the goal that people want mark so
so the first one is e or i
can't do this introvert extrovert right
sure this first one so if i'm an
introvert what's what's one thing i
should be looking at as a marketing
tactic
okay let's start we'll go extrovert
first i think what you said on the last
episode or two episodes ago
is is is one of the best things to do if
you're an extrovert talk to everybody in
your time
if you're new okay like that i can do
okay
okay if you're an extrovert yeah and you
love people so being an extrovert means
that not like i'm an introvert you're an
introvert yeah we've just been talking
for hours yeah it doesn't mean we can't
talk okay but i'm an extra what do i do
what do i do whatever you're an
extrovert you love people you feed off
people spend more time with people
what's my marketing tactic what's your
marketing tactic um
uh
have
have five coffees a week yeah and after
each one sign a thank you note and mail
it to them
i took that from my friend nikki pat
okay she has it all the time great she
loves the queen of literally making me
okay now i want that for every letter
what am i doing as an i
uh if you're an introvert
then
uh
i would well you're an introvert so what
do you do i know but
but it's not what i do now it's what did
i what did i do sure
what did i do um
pay-per-click
adwords to a landing page okay people
phone you okay i don't mind answering
the phone i'm not talking to people when
they're asking me questions
come to me and ask me the questions i
don't i'm not very good at going out to
you nice two goal tactics down what's
next what's the next letter what's the
next letter yeah it's uh it's n or o
okay uh no it's n or s one is observant
and one is intuitive great what am i
doing
like this is becoming increasingly
impossible now
okay hold on a second i'm i'm observant
or i'm what intuitive intuitive yeah so
what is it what is an observant person
what should they be doing this is
becoming them literally the myers-briggs
video yeah
i am i am but but myers-briggs isn't
usually parsed out to each individual
component because well let's say that we
need to add more value to mars but it's
a collection of four so if you're an i
in an s it's different than if you're an
i and here's the thing you're giving
them four different strategies and and
there's going to be some line i know but
they're like 64 different combinations i
got it so but but like in these eight
strategies we're gonna they're gonna
find something that they can use
okay so hold on so as we're talking
through these eight gold strategies that
are coming out of mark drager's mouth
yeah thanks just think all of them can
work
what do you because at the top of this
whole thing mark said you got to do the
thing that feels right you got to do the
thing that's for you
but finding that is difficult so by
going to the personality test we're
going to get eight different strategies
see which one feels the most right to
you
and double down on that strategy instead
of trying to do all late i don't want
you to do all eight
pick the one or the eight that feels the
most
right we're building up a lot of
anticipation for these eight
so we get gold beautiful okay okay
observant or i bought you a lot of time
on that one yeah observant versus
intuitive
right yeah so someone's observant so
what should they do for marketing to
build their brand so i use
16personalities.com yeah which is a free
service yeah and so that's what i did
yeah and that's where i recommended you
so based on some of their stuff what
they're saying is that um is that energy
is the next level so intuitive versus
observant okay so that's the second
scale okay and what that allows for
if you're asking me to like break this
down well the other four scales
determine how you interact with the
world
make decisions schedule your activities
or react external feedback the energy
scale actually determines how you see
the world and what kind of information
you focus on okay okay but let's pause
like
this is important because no don't pause
the camera okay
pause because
a lot of people will go and look at a
myers-briggs or read it or do it and
then they have no idea what to do
like what do i do with that information
i guess so i mean if you do the test
properly it gives you your strengths
weaknesses your relationship okay great
how do i market my business
right i'm trying to build a million
dollar agency i just spent 20 minutes
every single questions and get this
thousand page report what am i supposed
to do to market my company play your
strengths but that's so tell me what
this is what advice brings is
this video is good but people ask people
do these personality tests yeah and then
they don't know what to do from the work
the tactics like break it down my next
step what am i supposed to do
so if i'm observant it's how i see the
world
what do i what do i do with that i i
don't i don't think we can pursue this
the whole way because when i mean played
your strengths yeah what i mean is
well this brainstorm if it's not perfect
sure you know a thousand markers
i just have to know much better like how
these things actually boil down to the
really individual so let's do it this is
on the spot okay
observant is how it's how you see the
world
yeah it's how you absorb information how
you absorb information so so part of
marketing is being able to absorb
information right before you act on it
he's reading
yeah
i should like speed this part up this is
going to take a while to go through yeah
okay but take a look even if it's not
perfect we need eight strategies
i i know everyone you're looking for
this is super abstract
uh
okay
if listen if it's abstract it's not
helpful like myers-briggs needs to lose
a second letter if it's not helping me
what it
it's not helpful because the way you're
trying to take the tool isn't helpful
what i'm what i'm what i mean by play
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to parse out each individual
letter and then have it trait related to
it exactly right i need actionable
information if you're going to give
like make it actionable you want to help
people here's here's where it's
actionable so for example if you are
so you are an infj i don't want to go
through 34 different i'm not asking you
to what i'm saying is what i mean played
your strengths is you have certain
things that you're better and weaker at
right but i want to know what my
marketing tactics should be
i want to make this tactical i want to
make this helpful for people these are
people who are looking to start a
marketing agency yeah marketing company
but there's a lot of ways to market and
grow it
so
how do i figure out there's a lot of
marketing strategies everybody says you
know look at what you're good at i mean
i don't even know what i'm good at yet
i'm still trying to figure stuff out how
do i figure out based on
any kind of knowledge that i have what
marketing tactic i should are you just
saying try everything once no see what
sticks so here's here's how i break it
down
this is it the new myers-briggs better
than myers
that's nothing to do with myers-briggs
because it's better and here's nothing
to do with mars break okay good how do
you break it down at the end of the day
we've talked about this
we've talked about this before okay in
previous videos
the relationship is everything right so
yeah the the marketing tactic is
hopefully to increase your awareness
hopefully more people know about you
more people see you more people want to
talk to you more people see your work
they want to call you they want to work
with you they bring you the project they
say hey i want to work with you and
here's the budget and please please they
beg you please work with me yeah that's
the dream and that's the goal
in a marketing agency who whoever
whoever owns the relationship whoever
owns the relationship wins 100
right yeah that's all that matters yeah
so
when i say that you have to play to your
strengths yeah
it's all about what are the things that
you are good at
to be able to put yourself in front of
people
so that way they can get to know you and
what you're doing if you're an introvert
okay if you're not going to go out to
the world yeah if you're not great at
these things then you need to get in
front of people when they're looking for
your type of service okay and you need
to build a really great portfolio or
have really great credibility or have a
really great landing page okay something
to convince them to pick up the phone
and call you
or send you an email
right if you're an extrovert if you're
good at meeting people if you just love
the hustle and love that work
then you go out to the world yeah and
is it tactic picking up the phone maybe
is it sponsoring an event maybe is it
being a speaker is it being a thought
leader is it going on social media is it
okay all those things great maybe but
but the first thing to think about is
it's all about
building the connection and the
relationship right right and so are
people coming to you or are you going to
them right
next level down from that yeah right
exciting yeah okay so people are coming
to you yeah
your marketing tactic can't end at the
phone call right this is where brand and
personality and sales i know okay i want
i want to back up i want people coming
to me i want i want more specific on
people coming to me so so we did
introvert extrovert awesome
what else like if i'm analytical
versus non-analytical
is there something i can do that's
different
like if i'm if you're not analytical and
you're doing pay-per-click campaigns
you're dead
right
if you hate analytics and numbers i
would just hire someone who's good at it
to do that for you
sure but that's a starting point which
is what we do as a starting point your
first move should not be hire somebody
to do ppc or should it
your very first move should be hire
somebody to do ppc for you
well that's what i was getting into like
ppc is like the next video but yeah
because we're on fire
so okay so but but play your strengths
would then be like i got to hire
somebody you have to have a great
portfolio
you you have to have a portfolio yeah no
you say yes of course lots of people
don't have portfolios okay right you're
just starting what is it like as much as
stuff in there as you can you have to
have credibility okay so does your
website represent itself well yeah uh
and your brand that we talked about your
brand your website uh do you are there
is there anything that will lead someone
to believe that you don't exist yeah and
this is like really tactical stuff down
to the point of do you have an about us
page does the about us page have your
photo or show your team
is your address there yeah if people
don't know that oh there's a company
like address even if it's your apartment
yeah
oh there's no photos of these people
yeah they don't think you're real yeah
right they won't call you yeah so
are you credible do you have a portfolio
do you represent yourself well
right so that's for everybody that's for
every business that's ever been invented
but marketers especially do it badly
right so because they're so worried
about the front but it's not picking now
it's not picking a market these are what
like everybody has to do yes where
everybody doesn't have to be a thought
leader
so everybody has to
have a portfolio they have to have a
portfolio have an about page with
pictures they have to represent
themselves as real whatever that looks
like maybe it's a video review maybe
it's walking around your your office
maybe it's linking to your instagram
account something that shows something
that shows that you're real people
really what you're doing like your story
address and address address we're a real
place right if it's your apartment say
you can come by my apartment studio okay
right i work from i work from my shed in
my backyard like
those are those are core yeah whatever
you need to have all your social handles
set up
no so you don't get instagram it's okay
if you're good at it do it you don't
know guys
do i need to have it set up
no no okay so i need those three things
so so
to be an agency and to succeed you need
that website you need credibility you
need your portfolio right do you need
youtube or not website is the about page
yeah okay yes yes yes do you need
youtube or not yeah only if you're going
to be good at it and do it and like it
okay so then do you need instagram or
not yes only if you're going to be good
at doing facebook right if you're going
to be so i like this so we've got the
three tactics that everybody has to have
you have to if you don't have a
portfolio don't worry about going to
youtube yet build your portfolio yes
don't worry about your instagram account
build your portfolio yes build your
about page yes right you're awesome
awesome great so that's like for
everybody so that's those are for people
who are coming to you right so there's
three things that you need to everybody
absolutely has to do then there's a
million other things that you could do
right so how do we pick which one so
when you start to layer on top of so
that's your that's your home base right
like that's that's the thing of people
who are coming to you
right as you're going out to the world
they're checking to make sure you're
real and all of those other things yeah
okay so the next tactic above that yeah
is
either yeah you're going to go to
everyone you know
right tell them what you are doing right
set up your coffees right set up your
lunches yeah share what you're doing
yeah and like literally
blast every connection you have
introvert extrovert and and i say you
should do this or that but i think you
should actually do both so you should
you should do that okay and on top of
that
you should decide how you're going to
get people who don't know you to find
you so that can be adwords
right that can be
youtube yeah that can be in like being a
thought leader on instagram yeah it can
be social media yeah it can be going to
your local chamber of commerce like you
need one
activity of each
right you need to go out to all your
relationships right you need to meet
with these people and you should do
those things whether you're an
introverted extrovert because even if
you're introvert it's a one-on-one
conversation you still push yourself to
do that right you need to find one
tactic that's going to introduce you to
people who don't know you
google adwords
instagram
facebook
okay let me ask you this so if you're if
you're say introverted
we're gonna do we're gonna do some of
the extroverted stuff but do i want to
lean heavily on i wouldn't say
one-on-one conversations and coffees
with people is an extroverted thing to
me an extroverted thing is like i'm
going to go speak on this panel i'm
going to go sure it's more the how do i
get that person because going up to
somebody at your church who you don't
know and say hey i heard you are uh
that's more than sorry when i mean when
you're just starting yeah i mean i i am
literally gonna go through onto my
personal facebook and say hey guys i'm
starting this company i would love to
meet people that are like this right or
uh you're going through your linkedin
profile because you just quit your job
and you're literally scrolling through
and you're writing down a list
of every person that you may want to ask
for coffee for one-on-ones whether
you're introvert or extrovert everybody
has to do it i think you should okay so
i do
i do it once a year so it's part of our
three things now it's the fourth thing
is the next layer up all right you've
taken care of your home base you're
representing yourself with your about us
but this but you see there's no option
everybody has to do it
sure no but i don't want to put words in
your mouth no i think you should whether
you're an introvert extrovert it's all
about the relationship i get it how do
you how are you
how do you form and how do you nurture
and how do you build those relationships
if you can't if you're not spending time
with people
it's not about spending time with at
least what i'm thinking it's not about
spending time with people it's how do
you get that initial conversation to
happen
is it
to your point before i want i want to
have a system that makes my phone ring
because i'm happy to talk to people then
go meet with them or i'm going to be out
networking
and shaking hands and meeting new people
and going to industry events right i'm
not saying that that's the introvert
versus extrovert right what i'm saying
what everyone should do though is tap
into the people that they know in their
lives right so that's the core that's
okay so it's literally you know
home-based we talked about the woman of
the church yeah i should go out for
coffee with my pastor right at the
church who knows everybody and say i'm
trying to do this is there anyone you
think i should be connected with right
regardless i'm i'm going to my cousin
because my cousin is in this company and
saying hey does your company can you
connect me with anyone right so
everybody has to do this yes
great and and you should do it at least
once a year
awesome keep doing it yeah i mean i mean
that's your home as your group grows and
it's only 1200 people that you that
you're talking to and whatnot that's
where home base gets you split up yeah
this is your first tactic and everybody
must do this tactic everybody needs to
have their website
their about page their portfolio
if you want to be a successful agency
you need to have those things your
website your about feature before be
honest about your address how to contact
your address your story like phone
number like no like hello whatever.com
great that's that's foundation home base
next your first step everybody's first
step after that from a marketing tactic
should be to reach out to everybody you
know and say you started this business
and you're looking at targeting go back
to a video around customers who define
i'm targeting people in the automotive
industry do you know anybody i'm
starting this company can you make
introductions everybody has to do that
so like it's our next path great but but
yeah but when you're doing that don't
just send out like an e-blast don't just
go to facebook and make it easy okay
awesome awesome like do you think we can
we'll talk about the next video but in
the time put in the time i love it i'm
looking at the next tactic though
because at some point it breaches out to
a million different versions yeah and
you have to and you can't do everything
so i have to do these three things and i
have to do this one thing
then it starts to bridge
what how do i pick so if i'm extroverted
i'm going to go to conferences i'm going
to be meeting people i'm going to go to
as many events as i can in my industry
if i'm introverted i'm going to be doing
ppc i'm going to be doing
instagram posts i'm going to be doing
analytical stuff behind the scenes does
it break out more than that
uh so on the extroverted side do you
want to host a podcast or a radio show
do you want to is your dream to be on
television do you want to write a book
do you want to become the industry
leader right but can we help them make
that decision because if you say are you
more interested or extroverted people
can
usually as some people fall in between
but most people can lean one way or the
other then it's great then we cut off a
whole bunch of
options that they don't have to worry
about like you can still win focus on
these things yeah so if i've picked i'm
an introvert awesome
don't worry about going to as many
conferences and events
you could win there but you probably
won't win as hard
go do these things yeah okay if i've now
identified this is what i'm trying to do
with the myers-briggs if not identified
as the eye great is there any other way
to split up those things are you just
saying
test everything or just see what feels
right or can we give more context to
people to help them make a better
decision
everybody
should know what they like and don't
like doing let's say that you may not
know what you're good at and bad at but
you know what you like doing and don't
like do it but you haven't tried it how
do you know if you haven't tried doing a
pay-per-click campaign like how do you
know i'm not saying pay-per-click
what i'm saying is computer work you can
build your business
off of
and lead generation
off of
producing
a passion project
okay right so so if you are a creative
agency that's into design you can choose
to design
posters and pour yourself into that and
then put that into a design community
forum right and then that will get your
name known and your agency will start to
become known or if you're into video you
can go to vimeo and you can get a
editor's choice award for a passion
project and that could be the way for
the introvert to build their business
through their work right through
becoming known and through lifting your
way up and it's not like a long shot it
happens to a lot of people where they
let their work sell sell them do we then
just refer back to the the other video
on how to make the right decisions based
off of
your gut feeling how to trust your gut
more but it's not just gut it's it's
taking advantage of of
like really going into your strengths
so i like helping people you like
helping people yesterday i was having a
meeting with someone where i spent three
hours with them i don't think they're
gonna move forward okay i gave them
every way that they could they could run
their business without us yeah because i
don't think really were a great fit and
they kept apologizing about the time i
said no no i like i will invest time so
i chose long ago to hire people to do
different things so i can free up my
time because me spending time with
people
is lead generation and i'm an introvert
but me spending time with people me
having a long conversation with them me
getting them thinking
is the way that i actually
generate business generate work and
generate leads because i'm good at that
but if i was much better at my work like
the actual design the actual programming
the actual whatever it is i would come
up with amazing things and i would or i
would write a if i was a better writer i
would write a blog on that because
because i'd be so inspired by the work
we're doing if i was really into
analytics i would want to crack the code
for the most analytical way to go about
something and build my business off of
that
there are lots of at your desk things
you can do where you want to try and
carve out your space and your niche
through your work i choose to use
pay-per-click because people are calling
me and then i give them tons and tons of
advice and time yeah everything for free
i will pour myself into them they'll
move ahead or they won't move ahead
that's my lead generation sales it still
becomes like how do i pick i still don't
know how i pick
if i'm an introvert and there's still a
million things i can do how do i pick
pay-per-click instead of but if you're a
marketing agency you should be able to
pick for yourself but if i'm starting i
don't know then i need to figure it out
but but you have an idea of the type of
marketing agency you want like like i
understand if you're a bricklayer you're
saying you're a bricklayer and he
doesn't know how to pick to grow his
business cool he's a bricklayer we're
talking to marketers here we're talking
to creative people these are web people
these are video people photo people
design people like these are people who
have an inherent skill
right
if if you're if you're uh
if you're the conductor of a symphony
would you not use that talent to market
yourself would you not be like i'm gonna
design um four different songs for the
four different seasons and release them
i'm gonna write like like you would use
your skill right yeah you need the
website and you need the portfolio
people who are trying to get there and
they don't know yet
they're trying to figure it out i'm just
trying to shook at their path right and
you're saying if you don't know you suck
basically you know
i'm saying look within yourself
but it's not great advice like yeah it's
it's it's ultimately the best advice but
i don't know what to do with that how do
i look within myself if if if you can
figure out if you can hack yourself what
i'm trying to get to do is hack yourself
because yes you could you could randomly
meet somebody at the airport and that
could be the person who
ends up blowing up your business but if
you're an introvert like that's not a
great strategy to
to put yourself in situations where you
have a low percentage of what instead of
a high that's all i just want to
increase the people's percentage of
winning to a higher one but so i guess
the reason why i'm i'm not being super
specific about it because
because we are not really speaking about
sales and what we're talking about for
marketing tactics should flow directly
into sales and so if you're such an
introvert
that you don't want to have a
conversation or don't really want to get
out there or talk to people or even
one-on-one i want people to come to me
no i'm a magnet i love one-on-ones this
is what i get off on the most so i'm the
same way but i'm a magnet instead of
going out right and
which is which is why you set up a
landing page and you have adwords and
you drive traffic to it but here's the
thing like and then once you build that
up you do you know marketing great i as
an introvert who who builds a youtube
channel and does a lot of speaking and
and does books and all that
i don't have any pay-per-click
advertising
right right but if we look back through
your youtube channel yeah we have year
one with i'll do it for you we'll have
your one with this growth year two with
this growth year three with this growth
and and you take off at the at the end
of the day yeah
your greatest ability is to
work with the people you already know
who are or who are warm leads
or to be introduced to people who are
looking for exactly what you have to
offer go back and watch that video
through adwords okay
like the that that those are your core
elements listen we didn't get as far
down as what i wanted in my mind but but
i think we still provide a lot of value
i think at the core people have to have
a website
they have to have an about us and ours
tell our story and have your portfolio
right you have to have those three
things then you have to everybody reach
out to everybody in your network and say
you're starting this business and here's
the type of client that you want to
reach if you don't know who your client
is go back and watch the video from
before because we helped break that down
it was awesome then you can go in
extrovert and introvert and we talked
about different options from there
you're on your own but we gave you tons
of value that can really sell if you get
that far
and hopefully that helps because that
alone gets you to the point where you
should be making money in your business
yeah even if even that first step those
home base and then reaching out to
everybody should get you some business
coming in and then we help make the next
decision and at some point now you're on
your own today we're talking about the
three biggest mistakes that agencies
make when they are marking themselves
number one
what do we got
number one is uh and we all fall into
this trap you have to pay to play
okay we tell it to clients but sometimes
we don't want to do it ourselves so what
does that mean pay to play what it means
is if you want to be seen by people you
have to pay someone to do so right if
you think back to the old days there was
radio there was television people paid
money
to show it yeah and the internet comment
came along and we thought okay well we
can create a viral video we can blog we
can do all this free stuff and people
will just find us okay but truthfully if
you want to save time if you want to
find the right people and you want them
targeted you have to lean on google
adwords
all right which is pay-per-click where
you can
have the different ads that you want
based on different search terms yeah
people come in and they find you you can
go to facebook right we're creative
people we can design uh banners we
design videos we can boost posts yeah go
to facebook around who we want to target
what they're interested in yeah and we
drive traffic to the site yeah we don't
you know at this point with our clients
i can't recall the last time we ran any
kind of activity without the expectation
that there would be some advertising
budget got it that people would put a
thousand dollars a month or 800 a month
or 5 000 a month whatever it might be
that they would put money towards
finding people who are looking for their
service
and dropping them there right
is it the fastest way to grow right now
the fastest way to get awareness yeah
fastest way it always has been right so
so we we it's the most expensive way but
it's the fastest way
well it's expensive if you're not
tracking anything so i mean that was
that that was going to be our third
point yeah we'll just move it up to
number two okay number two right you got
to track you have to track
like it it's it's mind-boggling to me
that people put money towards things
without tracking yeah and so
you know maybe like google analytics is
pretty confusing i find it confusing i
have someone who can help me yeah but
but at the very least you need to be
able to track your uh goals so set a
goal do we want awareness yeah do we
want people just to see it do we want
conversion do we want people to actually
click through and come through do we
want a conversion on a sale
there are
there's software for call tracking so if
you have a phone number you can you know
we pay a service and it's 35 a month it
goes to all our numbers so we know if
this person came in through at google
and called us we can attribute that lead
to that call
right there are all these different
things available they're not really that
expensive they're not really that
complicated but it's all with the
intention of being able to get to a
place where i can say i spent 800
and i closed a 10 000 deal
right or um i spent two thousand dollars
and i closed a hundred thousand dollar
deal yeah i mean there's a lot of
wasted bad leads in there and it's like
eight dollars here and ten dollars there
and all the stuff but then the client
comes along that's the client you want
you win that client you keep them for
five years that client refers you to
other people and year over year
you know it's it grows your business but
people one are not willing to spend
money on it and they should
and then people too are not tracking as
much as they can and they're just
wasting money on stuff if you're if you
i mean would you would you fly
uh you know would you fly across the
country um stay in a hotel for a few
days speak at a tour
uh with the intention of closing a deal
and then coming back and never tracking
if you know would you do that right or
would you say no no i want to meet three
people and i want one of one of those
three people to turn in something if
that happened it was successful it was
worth the the four thousand dollar
investment right right i wouldn't do
that i don't like yeah so why when
you're spending money with facebook or
with google or uh with any kind of
activity would you just put money in
because you kind of know sales are
happening and not worry about what it's
costing and of all your marketing
tactics it's the easiest to measure
versus a tv spend or a radio spend or
something else yeah i mean it
it should be right right so it would you
say that every agency now needs to have
that capability either in-house or be
working with somebody to help them
so i'm a bit biased yeah uh i think it's
the only thing that matters
so you can so
so
when you say when we started off by
saying you have to be able to understand
and drive value for a client yeah how do
you explain what that value is right
if you
don't know kind of what's happening so
so if you're a creative agency and
you're in charge of branding yeah well i
mean you've succeeded if you've created
a really great brand so you don't really
need analytics okay but if you're
responsible for any kind of lead
generation any kind of spend any kind of
activity that you can and should track
it's it's core right like it's not good
enough that you created something that
made people feel good right unless if
that's the intention if you're a
creative agency are you not testing any
of the stuff on an audience
you may if the client if the client is
interested in that but but you're not
forcing it as an agency to say hey let's
get some feedback okay not typically
because because if you're doing closed
panels people don't have a tendency of
telling the truth got it and it's very
skewed uh and if you're doing uh open
online surveys or driving traffic in
certain ways um i mean if you're if
you're doing a name or something and
willing to test it that would be a great
way leveraging ppc to drive traffic top
three places in order of where i should
be spending money right now
uh
i i still believe that google adwords is
the number one platform to start with
okay because now
uh because
intent
well because search intent is there yeah
which is very very important yeah and
through negative keywords you can
tighten up your campaign very very well
uh
you can target your geography you can
decide your ad spend i mean the larger
more national you go the more cities
you're in the more generic you go the
more money costs and you're still doing
this for phantom yeah yeah yeah i wish i
could spend more on it i mean i just i
like we're in a we're in a pretty niche
industry but we also pick the terms and
the services right that we know we like
conversions so it's attracting your data
right right so as a marketing agency
though we don't buy marketing agency
okay we don't buy design agency okay we
don't buy branding so what how do people
pick we pick based off of the terms that
we know we have a very high likelihood
of closing okay based on competition so
there are a lot of marketing agencies
but if someone types in marketing agency
or marketing agency
chicago right like that is a very
generic term if someone was looking for
a
photographer
uh
video production company um uh lead
generation company uh landing page
design company right like those are so
specific that they can come in you can
talk about that one tiny project where
you can impress them with what you're
doing and then grow them into a bigger
company now you used to do videography
as your main business before you
expanded video production video
production sorry did you did you take
out ads for video production toronto
video production marketing and that
converted for you uh yeah i mean so so
we can go back to the glory days of seo
but we became a million dollar company
based off of seo before
before the good days of people but
adwords is still a part of that piece no
there's a lot of seo
so you know in the old days you used to
be able to invest in in blogging and
content and linking right and then you
can start to rank like we
at a time we ranked above wikipedia for
the term video production right right
like we went we ranked very very well
and i think we had 35 number one
keywords okay so
in in the fall of those days let's put
those behind us
adwords has become more competitive
uh there it costs more
but you have more data to track than
ever
and so if you're in the type of business
where your average sale is four or five
hundred dollars
it you know you don't want to be
spending too much to acquire that client
unless it's going to lead to more right
if your average sale is 5 or 10 or 50 or
100 or 200 000 so you're trying to more
than break even off your adwords
uh
yeah so
i'm not sure i understand the question
what do you mean more than break even so
you want to return on your investment
right but you're some people look at
adwords it depends on the industry so i
was curious about yours yeah they see
adwords as as break even if i break even
off my adwords campaign it's awesome
because i keep that customer there's
referrals there's repeat business oh for
sure so but you so what do you think in
terms of how much you want to spend is
it i want to spend up to how much i'm
going to make off the first gig with
them or up to half of what i'm going to
spend on the first gig with them
like if i make 500 bucks yeah per client
so if you make 500 per client do you
really want to focus on return on
advertising spend right because it's not
enough your cost of acquisition but what
they're saying really so then that falls
into lifetime value right yes so if you
can calculate your lifetime value of
clients right then you still want to
right-size that because your margins are
so little okay
right so if you're dealing with with um
and like in my opinion if you're dealing
with anything of multiples of tens of
thousands of dollars yeah per closed
client yeah then you're willing to go
much
looser yeah on it uh especially if
there's recurring revenue tied to it
yeah or you have uh the chance to hold
on to that client got it for a long
period of time
for me i've hit the point in my business
where i really don't care how much we
spend okay i outspend every single month
okay so google but then why not do
showing us media
agency or marketing agency
because we're not
so so there's a difference between being
able to spend the money and generate the
person to the page right and then being
able to convert that person into an
inbound sales
it's just not converting indeed
right you would spend more for the leads
you're getting but
more and i would be competing against
we'll go back to competition right i'm
not bumping up against certain people
right now
right i'm i'm i'm bringing people in
through the tactics that we are the very
best at right we are you know if i was
the very best designer yeah but i could
also do websites and other things i
wouldn't compete against website
companies right i would want people who
love design to come in yeah and then
once we're having that conversation i'd
say we also do websites and all these
other things so that's the strategy we
use we bring people in and the tactics
that we are the very best at where we
are the most competitive at that that we
are amazing at yeah and then once we
have that conversation we built the
trust we have the credibility we talk
about the other aspects of our business
everyone should be using google adwords
every marketing agency
provided it doesn't by month three prove
well we don't want to work we're doing
number two which is analyzing
like you may not i mean yes yes
everybody should do it right and to kill
it until it proves right that it's not
working number two is number two would
be would be facebook facebook and number
three
uh
but there's no number three google i
mean there's two platforms right there's
google and facebook so within within
google
you should be doing adwords to a landing
page yeah you should be doing
remarketing because it's so cheap it's
so affordable it's so simple yeah
remarketing is just introducing display
banners is that a third point
remarketing uh no oh what's that point
something else okay good yeah so you
should be doing adwords you should be
doing remarketing you can
your creative agency so if you can
design something or you're an agency
yeah i mean it makes sense to get into
youtube free roles if you ask me um from
a remarketing point of view or an
awareness it makes sense on facebook to
do an awareness campaign or this or just
conversion campaign okay
you know the idea of boosting
likes right nothing is it a terrible
conversion rate like the easiest one to
because they promote it so hard yeah but
what do likes tell you right like
anything i want i want people don't want
to worry about the metrics
so those those are the areas that i
would suggest okay so the one we skipped
was email marketing oh the third one
okay we're gonna skip that so like so
google number one facebook number two
yeah and then remarketing on the various
platforms number three exactly and then
make sure you're tracking analyzing
everything yes that's point one point
two is tracking and then point three you
wanna talk about the mistake people make
is under leveraging email got it okay
right so email marketing i mean i don't
know how many times mailchimp and all
the other suppliers can say it's it's
proven to be the very best
it's the very best converting
uh
potentially lowest cost yeah under
leveraged resource that exists for a
business and what's the best way to grow
my list
so
the size of your list is a relevant
targeted list
whether people love you believe in you
and like you follow you part of your
tribe is what matters more than anything
what's my best tactic though to get
those people on my list so it's to offer
value i mean it comes down to value so
if i'm if i'm building uh so as a
marketing agency
most
of our people within our target persona
list and most others will be the same
it's it's friends of the brand so these
are people who know you love you
believe in what you have to say believe
in what you have to do but but make no
mistake they will never refer you they
will never buy anything off you because
they're like a professor or a student or
whatever but they're still important
they're friends of the brand then there
are
your clients
people who are your clients who can work
with you and believe in you and then
there's your competition and your
competition is either competition or if
you're a thought leader in the industry
there are people who are learning from
you right and
why not teach those people
it's great to elevate yourself as the
leader is a monthly email a weekly email
what are you sending it
so it depends on on the resources you
have in house right consistency is
everything
consistency is everything right like in
youtube oh yeah they've been shouting
for years yeah you only do once a month
yeah do once a month yeah if you do five
times a week do five times a week yeah
consistency is everything so you need to
be able to know for you know you have to
decide is the content i'm releasing and
the same for blogging as well but is it
for my friends
and then what what do they get out of it
right people come because they want to
be entertained or they want to be
informed so what do they get out of it
is this for my current client base is
this for my competition or the people
who are in my industry yeah because i
want to teach them something and so when
you're releasing this content how much
can you write is it is it written or is
it video is it photography is it sharing
really amazing case studies but not
boring case studies but like the story
behind the work you're doing yeah is it
about your struggles as as growing your
business yeah
anything that you can do as a youtuber
or instagrammer you can release very
very well through emails
yes it's a great platform so would you
do an ad campaign on ppc to build your
email list is it that valuable like
would you spend money or is it just
something that you'd put on your
on your website say hey here download
our white paper as a lead magnet kind of
thing but like do you pay to get it
would you pay we don't typically do a
lot of gated stuff for ourselves okay so
um but you know we have tested with with
a hubspot like driven campaign yeah
we've gone through hubspot we've done
the drip nurturing
and and we were able to grow our list a
little bit okay from 600 targeted people
to like a thousand okay but um it wasn't
even as successful as if if we want to
do a camp if we just really want to
build our list yeah then
have a really great blog yeah
because the blog content is in line with
email marketing right uh potentially
start an activity like uh instagramming
like like live stories like the way that
you do right youtubing but you're not
doing this stuff i'm not doing so who
goes on your list like clients
you add them to your list like somebody
who signed up as a client you put them
on your email list yeah so then what's
your frequency now once a month once a
quarter oh no far less than that we send
it out maybe twice a year twice a year
and so it's like what you're most proud
of your work
we yeah we have leadership
we're not great at this right now yeah
because we are it's the most
underutilized
marketing tactics to be honest with you
like like
and i know it sounds like excuse the
last eight months we've been like really
busy it's a good problem
yeah i know but i would but this is
something that bothers me i'd love to be
able to do that but even twice a year is
better than
zero right so what we do is we try to
look for every opportunity to try and
make things as as personal and brand
feel as possible right so for example uh
three or four years ago canada came out
with a anti-spam legislation yeah
basically really really strict rules
that said businesses cannot email anyone
unless if you're a client yeah they have
expressly given permission right europe
has something similar okay so am i on
your list uh you may be okay i don't
know whatever that's fine but when we
sent out that thing we sent out like the
cheekiest like we everybody sends it out
you literally have to yeah we're like
we're gonna make we're gonna make this
thing people are gonna love us or hate
us yeah so we sent a picture of the team
uh i think our h1 was like you know like
like you know do we look like a bunch of
spammers of course not and it was just
the longest was basically making fun of
the legislation yeah okay
we had i don't know we had i had 15
people email me personally to be like
that was amazing right it was great all
right
but it's like it's a boring legal
information yeah but but it's not a
giant list it's not like 20 000 people
on this list either it's like customers
and yeah customers and people so so i
always go through and i actually
manually uh like update my list because
it's right constantly being so quickly
who's on the list the types of people
that you put on the list manually yes
customers uh
so i manually put customers on the list
that's it that's all you can legally do
oh okay that's all you can so every
customer you've worked with gets on the
list and twice a year they get an email
from you talking about projects what
you're excited by that kind of stuff
yeah or or if you know we're if we're
trying to boost some awareness for a
specific event or that we're sponsoring
got it right so so there's the like
there's also the idea of
and i don't know if this is something
people don't do but it's it's be seen
but then be seen being seen okay right
like you're gonna sponsor an event yeah
and it's cool that you just showed it to
the 400 people the event yeah
the bigger impact is to be seen
sponsoring the event by the 20 000
people who are on social or wherever
they are yeah right so you always want
to think in terms of rings and email is
a really great way to drive you know to
take the blog content you're already
writing and send it out and remind
people of it to say hey um my team had a
you know here are the top 10 photos from
our instagram thing and just send that
out right like it's this extra play that
you can go into and of course
if you're a more traditional business
offer codes yes sales all that stuff
you're not going to do that i love email
like i have 1.6 million at the time of
this filming on subscribers on youtube
that's when i talked to you at like 8
000 people no no on youtube on youtube
oh okay but and and email is coming up
on a hundred thousand okay almost there
like 97 or 98 yeah but if i have
something i need to get out email is the
way it's going to do it sure yeah and i
love what you do about it because i i i
mean i can tell the emails that are a
little bit more structured and then i
can see the ones where you're just like
telling a story hey
everyone it's easter weekend yeah my
friend mark needs to start a youtube
video and you need to go out and just
blast everyone on this thing so
but email's totally under leveraged and
it's something that
and i mean email doesn't even have to be
email marketing yeah like anything think
of 12 people that you want to talk to
yeah send them an email yeah
say like hey i was thinking of you how's
it going especially the beginning too
right to build your brain yeah
cool okay so the three biggest mistakes
not doing enough on ppc yeah not being
willing to pay not being willing to pay
not tracking your data not doing
analytics and not using email enough
i love it
mark runs fanta
he's been how long when did you hit like
how long ago have you been milling plus
six years maybe six years ago he hit
million plus yeah awesome and and today
we're going to talk about how to scale
so seven i think you're six or seven
we've crossed a million dollars you're
successful yeah how to scale how to go
from like just being a solo entrepreneur
to now building a team and building up
the company because as we covered in the
previous for
the previous video
you can't build a million dollar company
all on your own and so
you've got 12 full-time people
you've got
tons of freelancers work for you
what's your advice on how to go from
being that sole entrepreneur to scaling
your company
yeah so the biggest thing that you have
to do is is obviously know what you like
and don't like and know your strengths
and weaknesses yeah right you always
wanna
so a lot of us
when we're starting we feel at least i
felt like i had to be the smartest
person in the room okay i had to feel
like this is my company so obviously i
know everything and i guess lucky for me
there's so many parts of the business
that i know that i'm not good at
when i find someone who is much better
than me at it i'm like thank goodness
you're here like i cannot wait to bring
in people
uh who are better than me okay at what
they do
and that's that's the kind of
multiplying effect that in a creative
agency that um
i didn't think about and i don't know
many people if many people do
is that when i'm one person i'm not only
limited by my skill set and my time
but i'm also what's selling and doing
account managing and trying to do the
work or trying to manage people and all
these things and when i bring in two
people it doesn't only double i mean it
doesn't purely double the amount of
productivity you can have yourself to
manage that person yeah but it doesn't
only double that there are now two
people it actually raises what the
agency is capable of because the person
i'm hiring if i hire you you're let's
let's be frank like evan is really good
at coaching people and speaking to
people suddenly i hire you fanta has a
new coaching division of the business
right we're now the experts at coaching
because i can leverage your credibility
i can leverage your background i can
leverage all these things right and when
i go from two people to three people
michael on my team 20 years of
experience with analytics with product
management i'm not a product manager
yeah but he has been a product manager
at really big companies and so when we
work with a client
and he's talking about skus and
warehouses and all this stuff like i
have no experience suddenly fanta has
the experience right and so i almost i
wasn't aware of the magic that comes
from each person that you can add who
can be better than you who can elevate
the company who you can leverage your
experience now it can go the other way
right you can miss higher i've misheard
lots of people you can miss higher and
it can be kind of a downer but the way
that i look at people and scaling in the
way that i suggest most people do
is not only look at the person who can
do what you want them to do but that's
an opportunity to grow your story to
grow your brand to grow your
capabilities and you can sell
you can tell the benefits of having that
person
who should be the first person somebody
how do you figure out who my first hire
should be it's going to be your opposite
so if i'm really great at sales but i'm
terrible at operations and delivery and
production i need a production person
i'm really great at design but i'm
terrible customer service i need a
customer service and account manager if
um you know really
within our industry like you're either
really good at the craft and then you
need the business or the sales person or
you really i i was much better and i am
i think much better at the the sales and
account management side really our
business took off when i was able to
afford you know a better producer a
better director or better camera people
better editors better photographers uh
better people like wireframing better
people at strategy than me like like we
have been the reason we have a core team
of 12 and then lots of freelancers is
because in i mean i'd love to have like
18 people here like i want i want to i
want a business manager
because i struggle to keep on top of all
of the contracts and all of the legal
and all of the accounting i'm just not
good at it i don't like it
so we have big projects that never have
a contract signed and people like
where's the contract i'm like i never
signed it like eight months ago and like
that's not great we should be doing that
so so you look at all the parts of the
business but you start with just like
the polar opposite in my opinion of you
okay i'm really great at the craft i
want someone better at the business i'm
really good at the business i want
someone better to craft so that way you
elevate okay so that's from one to two
and when you go to three
or four or five
i i recommend you look at the areas of
the business that are
holding you back
meaning
so if you can't get things produced fast
enough
so in a creative agency the speed in
which you produce actually affects your
margins more than anything else okay
right and so so if you have staff on
salary
and you plan for them to spend you know
a week on it so 40 hours working on it
they spend 60 your margins are gone if
it's a freelance project though you
might say well it doesn't matter how
many weeks it takes because i'm only
it's a fixed price
but
it takes a certain amount of time to
sell something a certain amount of time
to bring into production certain amount
of time to work on it and and by the
time you get to the part where you're
delivering that stretched out project
you now have bodies working on something
that was sold and should have been done
three months ago and you're burning
through your overhead
and now suddenly you get to the next
part of it and you're selling your next
project you can't work on that project
because you're busy trying to deliver
the thing from three months ago right so
so when i mean the parts that are broken
or holding you back is speed of delivery
holding you back
are you making mistakes with
communications and then maybe you need
like a project manager
or maybe sales like your team is just
sitting around doing nothing maybe you
got to get more business maybe i'm
that's not your problem no i'm very
hesitant to say that okay because
interesting well because when we did the
last video series how to grow a million
dollar business i i had a sales person
at the time and i talked about how i how
three years in i i put the whole
business on the line to hire a
salesperson okay and
i hired uh someone who helped me a lot
and they were with me for seven years
yeah um they like i don't think fanta
could have gotten where it was without
that person i really don't like i
learned a lot we grew up together so why
are you hesitant to say sales is a
problem for companies because and i've
learned this since i mentioned that yeah
is people think i need a sales person
okay right
but a salesperson
most sales people still require lead
generation sure to handle them they
still require uh
great account management after the fact
sure they like they will they still
don't know your business as well as you
so you still need to feed them
information so they end up
so at a certain point they will help you
close some sales right but then it'll
start to shift to the point where you're
actually hiring other resources just to
feed that sales person just so they can
do their job and it becomes an actual
negative on the company well whether
it's sales or marketing like if you
you're saying what's the problem the
business it may be that
you're you're just you have too much
work and you have to hire people to
scale up yeah or you've got too many
people you don't have enough projects so
whether it's a salesperson or a ppc
campaign or yeah and most agencies
don't
so it's a bit chicken and egg like i
need the staff to make the sales but i
need sales to pay for the staff right
and so we always grew our business based
off of kind of um i don't even think
bootstrapping is the right word okay
it's more like
constantly flying apart at the seams
right and so when i hired so like if i
go through my order like when i hired uh
daniel who was my first sales person
like i had it was just me and him yeah
we hired our first editor it was because
literally was a sales person my first
hire that was real so i hired i hired a
pa
a production assistant to assist me and
this and that part time
full-time which was only with me nine
months and then the recession hit in
2009 and okay you know we were only a
hundred and eighty thousand dollar
company
but the first employee that helped you
grow your company was the sales and you
were doing all of the
video filming operations everything
everything else but i was responsible
even for trying to generate to do it
again
uh would i do it again if i started the
company again no much better sales now
so i would you would do the sales and
you would hire the team to do the rest
got it but first that's confidence and
that's expensive of course
no but my first my first real higher i
but i
um the company had zero money yeah all
right we it was 2000 and
just finished 2008. we ate through all
of our cash that we had on reserve there
was a three month period he had zero
sales yeah and i was going to close the
company down and then i called my mom
and i said i i you know i started 2006.
i was like
it's just too hard you know like why
have i given three years of my life
to do something that has no money in the
bank i didn't earn any income during
that time like i gave three years of my
life yeah yeah and and it was february
and um i hired
i found a salesperson
through uh
through a recruiter yeah i hired a
recruiter paid six grand for recruiter
found a salesperson
um andrew this amazing guy that we're
still friends with that uh i really love
to have on board and three weeks then he
quit
because he had been offered his dream
job right and he didn't know what's
gonna happen and he would never have
accepted my job if he realized and so
i'm left with like well i just spent i
paid him three weeks salary it really
upset me i got nothing for it and i and
i had no money yeah so i went out and
borrowed money i bored 40 or 50 grand
and i went back to the recruiter i said
find me the next person and then that
was when i didn't pay myself for six
months i cut checks and i paid that
person and you know like daniel
sacrificed a lot too so so that's the
thing like he came in not as a
salesperson he came in as a with a
partner mindset right and what i don't i
didn't realize then but most of my staff
most of the people who work for me
you know you said something about me
being a boss earlier and i'm like i'm
not really a boss i'm just the guy who's
kind of in charge um maybe it's the same
everybody has to listen to okay yeah
yeah
but i actually hire people i i think i
hire more people who treat me like a
business partner i treat them like a
business partner okay so i mean they're
not fully aware of everything on the
financial side right um you know net
profit margins and things like that but
when it comes to like guys how do we do
this as a business yeah they're on board
like how do we how do we how do we how
do we figure this out how do we change
this what's going to happen guys this
department is getting completely overrun
all hands on deck
like we're all
we're all
business partners we're all like but but
they also get the rewards from it we do
profit sharing models yeah so um
uh if you know staff have come to me in
the past who and have been like i'm
facing this life situation i don't know
how i'm gonna get by this month
financially and so
well we just cut them a check and hand
them a bonus
like i can't have my team at work not
yet work yeah and what i'm thinking of
like i want to
i want to own them right like i want to
own them but i'm not a boss no no
i want every aspect of their life
yeah and so i can't have someone at work
barely getting by so like it's the give
and take yeah it's the it's the like
this isn't you know yeah and first hire
freelancer or
full-time yeah a bunch of freelancers
what should the advice be first
because i mean i agree but because yeah
it's just the variable cost model so you
have to be able to keep your overhead
down
now we built our business a bit
unusually you are eating look at this
she's eating screw
she's eating a screw this is not dog
food okay you're going to stay on my lap
mark's a builder so
this is random that's great
he actually pulled this out of an
electrical outlet not just not wow not
just companies but he likes to build
stuff too yeah so um
so freelancer uh
yeah so we built our company a bit
unusually people what should people do
what do you think they should do well
but i'm biased so so i think you should
work with freelancers yeah when we
started our company everyone was working
freelancers yeah and freelancers are
four five six times more expensive than
full time yeah so i immediately said hey
hiring full-time is really expensive but
if i can hire full-time and then keep
them really really busy right my margins
are like amazing
right so we built our business that way
but year over year over a year
uh i love the freelance from all the
start because i also teach you to be a
better leader on a low yeah so
freelancers yeah is um
is
one i think it takes a long time to get
into a groove with some train yeah not
only train them but then train you
culture you're better than you are yeah
so they got to teach you you got to
teach them you got to work together you
got to develop shorthand yeah
and so i i would rather invest that in
people who are going to keep around now
we have freelancers who we've worked
with for six or seven years who are
still freelance yeah because every time
i look at the end of the year how much
i've paid them it still doesn't warrant
me hiring them full time right
but
but we like to we like to hold on to
people yeah we're good and the people
aren't good you know i love collecting
good people a lot of people who are in
this field are artists and they're great
at what they do
and
they hire somebody who's not as good as
them and they feel like this person
can't do what i do and then they get rid
of them and they feel like oh i'm never
going to scale yes
you know i i suck at managing i'm just
going to go back and
do everything myself
and that could work but you're never
going to be a million dollar company
doing it so how do you get through that
initial phase of like the first person
doesn't work out and this guy left and
he took three weeks pay
and i hired somebody but they're not
what i thought they would be and i hired
the wrong person like all of the bumps
that come at the beginning of hiring
because you've never done it before so
you suck and you get the wrong people
and they're not as good as you so like
how do you get through all that so get
used to the fact that
every time that you hire someone for a
role the first person will be wrong okay
like i like i i
i've been doing this a long time yeah i
feel like i'm pretty good at hiring and
yet
the first person i hire for any new role
doesn't seem to be the right person
been proven maybe once wrong like or
maybe
wrong once right where someone did come
in and they were just great right but
and so so gee so get comfortable with
that because you just don't you just
don't know what you need from the person
you kind of think you do you don't know
what you're looking for you know what
you need so that's fine so yeah so get
comfortable with that
uh the other thing is give up the things
that you're really good at last right
right so from the opposite your first
yeah for me i have very much struggled
in the company to give up copywriting
you're a good copywriter too this guy
this man is a
i admire his copywriting i look at his
he he could like
brain dump awesomeness that takes like
just out of nothing it's amazing yeah
but i have a good team as well but but i
have like it it has bugged me for years
where i go i'm doing strategy i'm doing
sales i should be focused on all of this
stuff and yet i'm doing this low value
copywriting why can't we find a
copywriter who can write copy and do
whatever i want this and that and yet it
may be low it's not low value it's just
low perceived value to me and right my
role in the business right and yet if
you have bad copy everything about the
project falls apart
and so i'm always like i'm i'm still
working on video scripts
so anyway we're all these years into it
and it's one of the very last things
that i'm willing to give up i think
creative direction or art direction is
the last thing i'm willing to give up
right um you will give it up at some
point yeah yeah yeah so how do you deal
with that is it just because you found
somebody who can actually do it better
than you or is on par with you if you
feel like you're amazing at it and you
give it to somebody who sucks yeah
obviously so one tool that we do because
i always look i'm like very analytical
yeah and i try to explain this to my
team we call it my way not my way right
or wrong
so think of a matrix four things right
there's like there's like my way not my
way right yeah so
if it's wrong it has to be fixed sure
even if it's wrong in my opinion your
way yeah it has to be fixed right if
it's right everybody's dandy yeah uh
if it's my way even better
but if it's not my way and it's right
it's right still i have to let it go
right everybody should let it go right
because then that's just me
micromanaging but right is what by the
metrics that you're right right is the
metrics right is like the clients talked
about conversations we've had it feels
right for the product we're really
trying to work to not get bogged down on
what
it's like just inherently i feel is kind
of like not my way right but the client
doesn't think it's wrong my team doesn't
think it's wrong yeah the designer
doesn't think it's wrong and so i just i
i've i let it go right and it's hard and
i let it go and then when something goes
wrong and the client comes back and it's
like
you know they like oh i don't really
like that i'm like oh i knew i should
have spoken up but that that doesn't
happen we talked about that in the gut
right like when it's screaming and
everyone says it's okay and i was like i
should have just done it my way
but you and i tell that to my team like
as as as i turn something over to
producer and that producer become has to
start to turn over to people below them
and then they have to turn things over
to freelancers i'm now five steps
removed from decisions that are being
made right like i have to believe that
every step below
understands the context of what's
happening in the best intentions in this
and that and the little things can
really mess you up
but you cannot grow a business having
every element of everything be perfect
right right you have to i mean you've
you've talked to me about this right
there's the world-class things yeah what
are you going to be world-class at
right i thought about it the other day
because i think my answer to you was
everything right i think my answer was
like i'm going to be world-class ad
account management and design and
analytics and development and this and
this you're like no
so
okay so one last thing i will say
because i mentioned about how like
things are flying off the handle all the
time we only hire someone when
that um
higher opposites are higher when we are
so busy yeah we couldn't possibly go on
another day okay
so
in our business you're drowning most of
these
like but you've been drowning for six
months right or eight months right right
our businesses have ebbs and flows right
the water's already in the lungs and you
don't know if
you're really really busy right now and
you're like you know the lord has
provided us and it's never going to stop
raining yeah and then nine months later
you're like where did all the business
go what happened right and you have all
these people here and you're like oh i
ramped up to be this business that i'm
not turning out to be right and so it's
mostly my comfort level yeah but but i
literally will wait like six or nine
months of just insanity and if it's
proven season over season that it's
still insane and it still looks insane
ahead then i go okay i'm comfortable to
hire someone got it but
you know a bunch of years ago i switched
my hiring practice from that model i
just mentioned yeah to we're going to be
a million dollar business so let's you
know we were 650 we're gonna be a
million dollar business so let's ramp up
like a million dollar business okay and
we didn't hit a million dollars we had
like 700
and then i think we hit like 920 and
then we hit a million dollars but for
three years i had ramped up to be the
million dollar business that wasn't
there right and in those years our
profitability like dropped yeah
yeah yeah yeah thank you
yeah whereas before that when we were
flying off the handle
like the most money we ever made was
when we were six hundred and
forty thousand dollar company they were
like
there were like four or five of us in
the business we were we were working
like crazy yeah and i went i'm ready to
be the big company i'm gonna become i'm
gonna hire the way the big companies do
yeah and that hurt us that hurt us until
like two years ago yeah when we made big
changes again and we started going like
forget this we need to be flying off the
handle
where do you what's that like what's
what does scaling look like for you now
are you good where you at do you want to
no so we're flying off the handle right
now well but where do you like what's
the future version what are you trying
to build
did you know
you're so freaking i haven't figured out
what's that you never have it figured
out okay
so
i know what i want to do for people yeah
and i know the value i want to drive for
them
and i know the types of clients who are
perfect clients
and what they should pay us
it's very hard to know
if all those things are going to align
when you're facing a project in front of
you and when you're halfway through
and things aren't quite good or they're
not going well you know like there was a
week two weeks ago where i was yelled at
by three clients like i had to have
really tough conversations with three
clients
one of them they were confused because
we were so busy they were confused by
the way we were count managing i had one
conversation someone else in my team had
another conversation we contradicted one
another we didn't know that we had
she and she was like what is going on
here and i'm like yeah that's that's
embarrassing yeah we'd have an open
conversation with her about like i'm
sorry yeah you know uh another i don't
remember the other one was another
client called at us
and was not pleased with some things
that were happening
last week i got i got destroyed by a
client
because of one mistake
one outsourced developer made on one
page of one site that caused the entire
e-commerce site to crash and it was down
for whatever 18 minutes yeah but
you know it was like we we
weren't even charging the client for the
work yeah we're just managing it to be
friendly yeah and uh
and you know like on a friday you know
even now like i'm i'm like you you feel
like garbage because of this one little
mistake from this one little thing yeah
and so when you have those days you go
like this isn't fun why am i doing this
right but then i have conversations with
people where i'm like i'm like hey i
have the opportunity to change your life
right like your business is here and
it's going to be here and if i can
enable you to get there not only do i
help you but i hope everyone that you
help right
right and you can make videos like this
inspire so many people it's fun right
it's fun but yeah so i hear you're here
but but i mean you know but could you be
do you see yourself being double the
size triple the size is that not how we
like we we need six more people right
now but you want to be like 10 times the
size
um
i think we should
i don't i don't know if it's what i want
or what we need or we need to do okay
right you know like like we're having
around two million dollars and that's
okay yeah um
and it's a very different company for
six or eight or ten million dollars very
very different company
and and
i don't have the the
i'm not opposed building that company
but i just want to know i'm more curious
why i would want to build that
right so if i want to build that because
it's like yeah i really want that 100
person team yeah and i really want uh
the 8 million dollars in revenue
like
for like an eight million dollar company
earns more or less the same profits
that a two million dollar company does
when you're in marketing because you're
going to go through these ebbs and flows
i mean if you're really eight million
eight million you're really tight really
good you're gonna earn a lot of money
yeah but
um but we do okay so it's got to be more
about about the capabilities
about how well we do it for me yeah um
and and
the the amount we are able to impact a
business right that's all i care about
well when we make out how to get to 8
million mark in the agency we'll come
back and do this all again
there we go
no let's go i'm pumped to see your
growth okay so like key takeaways
uh if you want to build a million dollar
business you can't do it by yourself in
this industry you have to you have to
bring on people you hire your opposite
don't hire the person who does what you
do hire the exact opposite stuff you
hate
start with freelancers and then work
your way to get full-time
uh let go of the thing that you love the
most last in your business
and it's not even the thing you love the
things you do your best thing that
you're best at right i don't love
copywriting i just think i'm good at it
and then expect your first hire
in each role that you hire for not to
work out to suck yeah it's unfortunate
and then and and you'll find your good
person on the other side of the
continuing to go through the hiring
process yeah yeah
cool
the last thing yeah
i used to be paranoid about it don't be
afraid for good people to leave you
right he used to motivate me to do all
kinds of crazy things and i would live
in fear and all this stuff good people
come and good people leave
a lot of good people out there your
company will survive anyway
all right don't be afraid for your
company to shrink by fifty percent
right you have i i have a friend a
mentor who ran a 40 person agency that's
down to 18 people and they're doing the
best work they've ever done
right it's not like like companies grow
in agencies companies grow and they
shrink and they go up and they go down
and you have good years and you have bad
years and and people come and people go
and and the company will go on yeah
right what you can do for people will go
on it it took me like 11 years to figure
that out
but i feel much more free now that i
know it hopefully they learn it faster
that's how we're hacking his brain there
you go this last one we're talking about
how to stay motivated as an entrepreneur
it's one of the things that i think
everybody can learn from whether you're
in the marketing agency or not
it's one of the tougher things you know
it's a lonely game especially beginning
when you're by yourself you're trying to
do this thing where people may not
believe in you when you have that voice
saying who are you kidding sometimes
how do you stay motivated what do you do
uh so
gosh i mean it's gonna sound like i'm
i'm really
preaching to the choir oh no i love it
no i know i know so so truthfully having
the work that you do
you know your channel your espresso
series
your one word uh there have been times i
think in august i was like man i need
more evan in my life like you know
listening to people who who can connect
with you yeah on a regular basis like
you're asking me what i do yeah you
already have videos on this so i can
just repeat back to you it's like oh
every morning you need to start off by
by having a dose of something to pump
you up yeah uh you know you need to
create an environment where where it
feeds you and all of this stuff and like
that stuff's all true yeah but your
story like it's interesting it's a
different perspective it's somebody
who's had success people
there's a lot of people watching who
want to build a million dollar business
plus
you know they see you they may not know
you yet but like to this series they've
come to respect your opinions and see
like he's he's a couple years ahead of
me like i want to get there so
you dealt with some
frustrating points
especially in the beginning of your
business where most people will quit
most people would not keep keep it
through keep going yeah so so like what
did you do to stay motivated in those
early days and then i guess even now
like now you're watching videos awesome
but like how did that those first early
moments when you were struggling
how do you get through it
so
there was for me it wasn't the belief of
what i could build it was the like i
really want to build a certain type of
company okay
i saw what others were doing and i knew
that i couldn't do it okay like i
physically like you know so we're in an
industry where you need a lot of smart
people doing a lot of things for the
magic to come together okay
and the only way that i can do the type
of work that i wanted to do the quality
that i would be proud of and have the
company that i that would produce work
that i was proud of
was to bring on other people and so
you know early on recognition certainly
helped you know any work that i did if
someone was like oh that's a great
project great job you know client client
feedback that feedback loop of you know
of being able to bring a client in
certainly uh helped
but
what kept me going is one knowing that i
wanted to build a certain type of
company
um
a hope that we would eventually get
there
and i you know early staff is like mark
i've been waiting for nine years for
this company to come around like we're
still gonna get there guys yeah uh so so
there's there's that
and then um
i really wanted to
i just i wanted to run and own a
business
and um so what do you tell yourself like
didn't you call your mom and say you
want to quit or like you were at your
ends into the rope yeah
yeah but i mean so in the february
february
2009 maybe it was whenever it was that i
was thinking about packing it in yeah um
it just came down to like i will always
kick myself if i
i said at the time i should just give it
one more chance okay
because if i don't i'll always it wasn't
that i would be a failure i would kick
myself and look back on this with regret
and
thank you so much thank goodness thank
goodness that i did i mean like like i
have people who go like i want the type
of company you have and i don't even
know how we did it yeah like i can look
back and piece it together
but it's year over year step over step a
little bit bigger a little bit you know
i'm always worried about about how can
we drive the most value and what like
i'm always trying to analyze what do we
actually do for clients and what are
people buying and what are we selling
and all these things
um so much so that i'm probably holding
us back from just you know years ago
someone said just find something you're
good at just do it a thousand times and
i'm like no every project has to be
different and everything has to be
custom and i can't i can't become a
machine yeah but
but mostly it's like i i want to give
this a shot
and then you hit a point i was talking
to you know a business owner who's in
year
two
building a website agency
and he's he's at this point where he's
just like i just i don't have enough
money to support the team i need and i'm
on this hamster wheel and it feels like
it's never gonna end you need the money
to pay the team you need the team to
make the sales you need the sales to
have the money to pay for the team
and the only thing i could tell him
which is what happened for me and it's
happened in twice now in two different
versions of fanta
is that it looks
like it's impossible
and then just one day
it's no longer impossible and you didn't
know when it changed
so in my house i'm i'm renovating in my
backyard
i'm doing this really big project in my
backyard and so i have this dirt like of
this bobcat this um this skid steer that
i have to move dirt to make a patio and
right now it starts hilly okay and this
summer is really weird i was like i was
in there and i have this this shovel and
this skid steer and i'm trying to make
it smooth with this really big machine
and the more i work it the less smooth
it is and the more bumpy it is and i'm
at the point where i'm like frustrated
like six hours in and i'm like broken
down and i'm just like i feel like i
want to cry because i'm like i'm like
i'm never gonna be able to do this yeah
and then like 20 minutes later i just
looked around and everything was smooth
okay i went that's weird and then a few
days later i'm working on something else
and i hit that point where i'm getting
really frustrated let me push through
this okay let me push through this and
then half an hour later everything's
smooth okay
and a few days later i'm working my
wife's car and i'm trying to hammer this
broken thing off and it won't come off
and i'm frustrated and i'm like and i'm
like i'm never gonna get through this
and then finally i take this really big
hammer and i'm like
well this thing has to come off and i
just hammer the heck out of it i spent
two hours trying to hammer this thing
off i hammer the heck out of it it comes
off okay ten minutes later i put it all
back together and what seemed hopeless
yeah right i just beat the crap out of
it right but then ten minutes later it's
all together and it's there that's the
piece that most people miss and that's
and that's what happens in business yeah
is right like is like you're trying
you're trying you're in the hamstring
the hamstring the hamstring and then one
break happens or you get a little bit
more revenue on one project i'm going to
apply this to this
or you push through and you when you're
about to give up you wait and then the
call comes and you get the project to go
ahead and suddenly that that one thing
you know hammering extra hard and
putting the extra effort in and it comes
off and then 10 minutes later it's done
like like in life
things turn really fast
and so this guy who's two years into his
web building business who doesn't have a
team that doesn't i'm like i'm like
don't stop keep going
all right keep going keep going because
suddenly you're going to get up project
and that's going to let you hire one
person which is suddenly going to
snowball into now selling three more
which snowballs into hiring two or three
more people and in like a year and a
half you spent all this time struggling
yeah and then suddenly you have a half a
million dollar business or a million
dollar business or whatever it is
and so when i started three years of
struggling
and then we were able to figure
something out and we became a pretty
good like four or five six hundred
thousand dollar business and then it
took us a few years to figure out how to
be a million dollar business
and then we were a million dollar
business with no growth for four years
in a row
and i was like well obviously this isn't
getting me
to where i want to be and i made and i
made some really big changes and i
rethought how i looked at the company
and suddenly we grow 50 or 60 in one
year and then i go well is that a fluke
and then i try to put that and it and we
put together a few more years of the
same so now i'm like okay i'm ready i'm
ready for the next one but you have to
push through the time where you're going
to give up where you're like you're like
this is a mess i've just made it messier
i haven't made my life simpler
but you push through and then suddenly
everything happens and it all comes
together and you're like
cool i'm a genius right and people pat
you on the back but meanwhile you didn't
believe you could do it and it's
everybody's i mean not everywhere it's a
lot of people's story the hardest part
is just getting up and doing the thing
every day and pushing through when it
feels hopeless i just didn't feel like i
had a choice
because of regret
regret uh i'm the i'm the sole
breadwinner uh you know first it was
like i start my company but you could
have got a job you could have gone back
and got a job if it's just me you would
have made more money at a job than doing
this i'd make more money at a job right
now it's okay but it's not just but but
you have a choice there in that if it's
just being a breadwinner you can make
money
doing a job
if it's the regret of i don't want to
look back in 50 years and say like i
missed my shot
yeah but it was also at the time you're
not realizing that it's okay to fail
right like like now that i've done this
yeah like if this all disappears yeah
i'm like cool what's next
like seriously like like i have i have a
great team and i'm like great how can i
save the team and bring them with me
wherever i'm going yeah your identity
was tied to the what you would you think
that saved it
i'm glad i didn't give up yeah but but i
think it would be more important today
yeah more important today is actually me
giving up right because because
truthfully
truthfully it's like we have
um
so i've been doing this for 12 years
i have a comfortable income it's not
where i want it to be i don't know if
anyone's income ever is but it's a
comfortable income i've got a good team
when days are hard now i go i go why am
i doing this like yeah like
i built up this company and i'm doing
all this stuff do i really need this
it's like i don't know if that's ego
yeah i don't know if that's um
getting tired because it's like you you
don't want to burn out or whatever it is
but um
yeah it's it's not it's not actually
when you're sitting there with nothing
saying spinning your wheels at the end
of the day and going like you're sitting
there and you're you're drinking a glass
of wine or you're crying and you're
confessing to someone yeah that you feel
like a failure i feel like you push
through that the the bigger enemy
are or the the days or the weeks or the
months where you go into work and you
don't want to go into work because it's
just not fun anymore where did that
magic go and for that
um i've kind of taken comfort in saying
like hey if you have a bunch of those
days or weeks or months in a row then
change your business like you're in the
wrong business you don't have to sell it
you don't have to get out like your
business is a vehicle
that you should be able to take anywhere
you want if if next year you check on
this video and fantas become an
electrical engineering company or
something it's like cool here i am the
expert at uh running an electrical
contracting company or whatever it is
because that's what i'm interested in
now right now i'm not going to like do
that to my team yeah i owe it to them to
keep going the direction and my clients
but
but yeah i mean like this can come this
can go all i know is that i'm building
something i'm bringing great people on
and i want to hold on to those people
wherever wherever this takes us yep
and how about now
staying motivated doing what you're
doing i mean you said you watch videos
what i'm doing that kind of stuff but
yeah so
i think it's really really important to
listen to things outside of the the
field you're in okay so um being able to
better shape uh
and things of interest right so
um i think people talk about like hey
you know entrepreneurs you got to work
out and take care of your body because
if you don't take care of your body you
can't do anything else yeah i think
people in their 40s and 50s hit that
page where they're mature enough to say
you got to do it
i still don't quite take care of my body
as well i'll worry about that later
right but i have hit the part of my life
where i'm like it's important to be a
well-rounded person okay and when i was
younger it was more like focus on work
focus on work focus on work and the
well-roundedness keeps you motivated to
still be an entrepreneur and push
forward yeah so like what what changed
what's something you do that you didn't
do before
um that's a great question something i
do that i didn't do before
that's the first time in 10 episodes
that i said that's a great question
actually no episode one episode one that
was
a great question
when i asked you three questions and now
episode 10 we have another great
question
you've been phoning it in the rest of
time all right good
that's interesting because i heard the
expression mailed it in
yeah you can phone it in or mail it in
but they're both forms of communication
yeah it's basically you just didn't show
up interesting
so anyway okay
what was my great question
so what did you do differently in the
past year or so that you weren't doing
before yes yeah so quite often i don't
take my laptop home with me okay at
night so that you can what spend more
time with the kids uh mark's got a
thousand kids by the way you started
with you started with a three month old
yeah rachel she's 12 now and now you've
got four six four
six six kids
six okay four kids not that bad actually
four yeah it's just a lot but i'm still
young for four kids yeah i'm 35 yeah
four kids yeah so um we so what do i do
uh you don't take the laptop home and i
don't take the laptop home with me which
means when i get home it's like it's
like dinner it's it's family time it's
put the kids to bed it's do the dishes
it's walk the dog it's make the kids
lunches
which actually means that like at nine
o'clock when i'm like i've done all my
stuff yeah i'm not tempted
to sit down and work till one or two a.m
okay so what's nine to bedtime
um just
whatever the heck out like netflix or
uh
follow a lot of people on youtube okay
read a lot like not books but i go down
rabbit holes okay resource stuff
uh i mean i'll blue sky i'll be like
i'll still think about work okay but i'm
not on my laptop which means it actually
like limits me to like just
like it limits me to like i'm not
getting into work mode because when i'm
in work mode right
and i still have to do it sometimes but
it will literally be one or two or three
in the morning and i'll be like looking
up it'll be like oh
and then i'll look down on my calendar
because i track everything in 15 minute
increments and i'll be like oh i started
this at 6 15. i've just been working for
seven extra hours on this one thing
and so it's it's slowed me down a little
bit but i don't know if that's a bad
thing
um i make an effort to come into work
earlier in the morning so i can so i can
give myself permission not to work late
at night because i'm going to come in
before work actually starts in the
morning uh i try to get in between seven
and eight
if i need to if i need to i'll come in
at like six yeah but but it sounds to me
like you're spending your evening time
kind of taking in the world
just what it's but it's it's it's the
only time of my
day yeah and my weekends yeah where i
can do whatever i want
so maybe if you're like maybe if you're
single so if i were single i would be
tempted to work all the time right i
would work all the time on everything i
would get up in the morning i would work
i would go home i'd go to bed yeah
luckily i have a wife and kids who
demand me to socialize right so so at
least it forces me to do that on the
weekends um i very rarely answer emails
or
now i still monitor them but i very
rarely answer emails and for the first
time um in the summer time when i took a
week off i didn't i didn't um
i didn't look at my phone
at all during the day
but that extra time that you're spending
that night is is not like i'm just gonna
shut off the world and
watch 18 hours of simpson or not 18
hours but like simpsons repeats it can
be if i feel i want to do that okay you
know if like if i feel like i just want
to like but do you feel like you need to
shut off the world i'm an introvert okay
like i need time to like recoup yeah
trust me man tonight when any time
we filmed all ten in one day and once of
course they see us wearing the same
disease
stuff we had we got up and went to the
washroom
but you know like go going oh man
getting the dog like gosh he's a pain in
the butt and forcing me to do my
lawnmower i love it
yeah i'm i'm why do you love the
lawnmower it takes him an hour to cut
the grass every weekend three hours
three hours three hours i thought it was
one no no wow you want a half acre giant
property okay so three hours to cut but
why is it your favorite part of the
weekend oh because it's like i might see
it's a little bit reduced because i i've
admitted this too many times so my wife
now knows what the deal is no it's on
camera i put i put i put music on i put
my headphones on i go out and cut the
grass
and it's not a time where i have to be a
father it's not a time we have to be a
business owner it's not a time where
anyone's calling me it's literally like
well i got to cut the grass it's growing
right and no i did podcasts yeah i'll
listen to podcasts i'll listen to
podcasts okay one and a half times so
that way it's extra efficient right or
that's fast people one and a half times
could you listen to my book when i have
speed really listen to ben shapiro
sometimes i want to have speed have you
ever really
yeah you gotta i have a hard time at
1.25 but i'm also not an auditory
learner it's the hardest one for me so i
have to slow it down anyway
so you listen to music listen to
podcasts for three hours every weekend
if yeah it's your ritual yeah in the
summertime sometimes the grass starts
stops growing but
uh
how do you deal with the winter
when it's snow blow okay i have a long
drive i'll break the leaves it takes me
an hour and ten minutes okay now that
one's less fun i have to say if you're
out on a beautiful sunny day kind of on
your lawn right and you know you see the
green you know it's my lawnmower is
pretty pretty like you know get the
headphones on that's amazing
snowblowing's on
shuffling it's not that much fun right
but it's still like oh i got to go on
something i got to go out and
get out of physical stuff but walk the
dog or do the like
even i enjoy doing the dishes i mean i
don't really yeah but i like that it
forces me to stand there yeah
and
think or watch something or learn
something
what are you usually doing when you
watch my videos or do i want to know
what do you think i'm doing well i don't
know i'm just kidding so i mean your
videos i mean
typically i'm watching the stuff early
in the morning okay so it's uh morning
routine yeah so it's either like as soon
as i wake up the only thing that can
wake me up is to start reading like if i
don't start like if i don't grab my
phone and start just trying to get my
eyes onto the phone huh like i will go
back reading an email reading a story
and yeah anything okay anything to
literally
okay force that light into my eyes
because i am getting up early and yeah
otherwise i will be very tempted or if i
have a meeting then i have to get out
right right right it'll be downtown in
another 15 minutes or whatever it is
right you rush but otherwise yeah yeah
like literally like yeah i can i don't
have to come into work at 7 00 a.m right
because i don't have to i can come in at
nine yeah i can come out at 10 right
who's going to say what
okay right so so you read on the phone i
read on the phone uh that's when i i
will pop in sometimes i get up before
your your
your 5 35 email goes out or whatever oh
the confidence 254 okay before a great
series everyone should look at it yeah
uh but
so i do that and um otherwise it's like
yeah in between like brushing my teeth
in the shower or although i i mean i
don't know how detailed we want to get
here i do brush my teeth in the shower
because it's a great way to save time
i'm with mark naked in the shower
i don't want your very own painting
okay i'm not with mark thinking in the
shower the other thing i do is because i
because i i i get up and i and i get out
the door quick and i grab a coffee on my
way in i have uh like about a 40 45
minute drive into the office here which
is great there's no traffic or anything
yeah the other thing i do is when i get
here yeah i find no matter how energized
i was when i woke up yeah it's like you
lost an hour and a half later okay and
so
or an hour and 15 or whatever it is so
sometimes i find as soon as i get into
the office i just open it up
um and just force myself to watch
something what do you want or i put on
oh there's something the videos
something from you or i put on music and
it's like dancing in the office and i
like to close the door because someone's
here or whatever it is but it's like i
need to get naked in the office and get
naked such a big window on this side
he doesn't do that
we'll stock mark and see what happens i
don't think anything i do is really that
uh extraordinary but yeah but
what drives me crazy is people who waste
time when they come in right right not
not my staff i mean even for myself
like to walk in the door and chit chat
make a coffee and talk no like like come
to work sit down and start working okay
and then you can look up an hour or two
later and go like oh hey it's whatever
time it is or sometimes i forget to eat
lunch or whatever it is but
final message to someone who's feeling
unmotivated
they're
watching this they're thinking about
quitting their business
yeah you know they wanted to learn
something in this series they they
clicked on the title
you know they might
based off of your answer yeah quit or
not quit yeah it's tough what do you
want to tell them it's tough
um
i would say
i would say that it's never easy but it
and and it's not always rewarding
but when you stop back and you look at
what you're doing if you have a purpose
if you know your one word
if you're focusing on momentum and not
the little bumps along the way
that
it will be worth it to push through
right it's never it's never i have a
friend who's starting a business who i
was talking to and he's just like i just
can't wait for things to smooth out i'm
like
never never happens
right so so
there are things you must love when
things are clicking
try to work for that magical moment
right like like try to try to get to the
place
where where you're like yes
this is really working and then don't
try to just hold on to that like keep
growing and keep building off that but
but find that in the little things
you're doing
right like i'm a perfectionist other
people might be i get down on myself i
know lots of other people get down on
what they're doing it always seems
broken
nobody has this figured out
right you know you work with some of the
ceos and the biggest companies they
don't have this figured out
right and so just just know that we're
all you know we said at lunch we're all
walking the same path we're all going
the same direction some people are ahead
and some people are behind some people
leapfrog and just stay with it if you
have a passion and you believe you can
do it
to see my one-on-one with grant cardone
on how he built a million dollar
business in 90 days check the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe i'll see you
there i'll tell everybody right now i
didn't hit the target spoiler i'm
calling home every night
on my new phone to my wife crying like a
little baby